a buildup of emotion of eight years of
working with some of the bests engineers
and technicians across the country that
put their heart and mind into making
this incredible moments happen for for
everybody
all right so that was a detailed look
inside dragon here's a live look at two
astronauts about to climb right in if
you're just now tuning in you're
watching our coverage of the mission
known as demonstration mission two or
demo two two days SpaceX and NASA are
going to be sending people into orbit on
a mission to the International Space
Station from US soil for the first time
since 2011 Bob bankin and Doug Hurley
are the NASA astronauts flying today and
you can see them right there on screen
they're just right next to their ride up
into space yeah very exciting so as you
can see they have already arrived at pad
39a where Falcon 9 will lift off from at
3:22 p.m. Eastern Time today they have
ascended the tall structure already
which is next to the rocket and it's
called the fixed service structure and
also have already walked down the
corridor which is known as the crew arm
which is what they're standing in right
now that's right and as they prepare to
board dragon they have this one final
stop they're standing in right now and
that's the white room white room is
literally just the room at the end of
the crew arm that has an opening into
dragon it is the last place on planet
Earth Bob and Doug are going to be
standing before they step into Dragon
for their ride to the International
Space Station and the term the white
room was first used during NASA Gemini
missions where the room right before
entering the spaceship was painted white
and as you can see we've continued this
tradition with painting ours white as
well and on Wednesday they actually
started a new tradition by signing the
wall in the white room it's a fairly
small area that has room for the crew
and a few ground support members to
complete cargo load at t-minus 24 hours
and crew ingress at t-minus 2 hours and
35 minutes which is coming up here
shortly and ingress is how we refer to
the crew boarding dragon also inside the
white room is a movable platform that
just gets extended out to the capsule
just to make that boarding process much
smoother for the crew to climb into
dragon as you might expect it's also
environmentally controlled you can see
kind of a big seal right up against the
the side hatch and that's just done so
dragon can be open while keeping all the
dust dirt and the Florida humidity out
of the
so making sure it's pristine for the
crew and so that seals gonna stay in
place until they begin to retract it get
the arm ready to move out of the way and
by that point the hatch already be
closed and the white room also has lots
of tools in order to open the side hatch
complete crew ingress and prepare for
any contingencies or emergency that may
be encountered and right now they're
just in the white room they're getting a
final brief and you can see them with a
number of different pad technicians
everybody on that team has a specific
job some are specialists who are gonna
help Bob and Doug get connected to their
seats some are specialists with the
Dragon capsule itself or they're gonna
be responsible for closing the hatch and
we also you typically have a
photographer in there just to help kind
of capture these moments as the crew
gets ready so right now we're watching
and we can see them start to line up
there we'll see Bob or Doug Hurley go in
first and so he'll be the first one
through the capsule and he's gonna be
ingressing that's just our spaceflight
term for enter and you're gonna hear a
lot of these terms throughout the next
couple of days as they make their way up
to orbit ingress getting in egress
coming out and they're also doing that
final Fahd check making sure that the
crew don't have any foreign object
debris dust dirt anything that could
interfere with the systems on dragon
just before they get it right as Leland
and Lauren were mentioning earlier they
do have stuff on their suits to protect
from Fahd and they have fog covers on
their boots as they mentioned as well as
on their umbilical port on their suits
on schedule listening into the nets and
hearing those updates live yes once the
fog check is complete they can enter
which is happening live on your screen
right now
and as they climb into dragon they will
buckle themselves in and attach their
umbilicals to their suits and as you can
see the suit techs are there to help
them get buckled and settled into those
seats and as we mentioned earlier in the
broadcast the suits primary function is
to protect the crew in the event of a
cabin depressurization so the suits help
keep them cool as well as delivers
nitrox in case there is a suit
depressurization as we go through this
we saw Doug Hurley go in first he's the
commander for this mission he's closest
to your screen and then Bob Jenkins just
next to him and they're gonna get some
assistance from these suit texts as they
get in there are four seats inside of
dragon for these missions and they are
numbered one through four if you're
looking from the perspective of the suit
text inside the hatch going from right
to left so Doug Hurley is in seat two
that's the commander seat and Bob bankin
is in seat three which four crew dragons
the pilot see obviously we don't have
anybody in seats 1 or 4 today crew
dragon is designed to carry four
astronauts though on future NASA
missions and we'll see that on crew 1
which will have three NASA astronauts
and one from our partner agency jaxa and
then directly above the crew right now
but right in front of them once their
seats get rotated are the three displays
that they'll use throughout the flight
and that just gives them insight into
all of dragon systems it allows them to
take control of the vehicle and manually
fly it which will see them do hopefully
only twice during to manual flight test
is again dragons autonomous but they can
jump in and take over if they need to as
Dan mentioned the displays are above
them right now but those seats will
rotate back for launch position so that
they can easily access those displays so
coming up next the crew will do a
contract once they're all settled in and
that's so that they can check to make
sure that they can hear Mission Control
and then after that their seats will be
rotated into position so let's check in
with John in sparker for the latest on
the health of both of those vehicle
John what's what's the status update
today we're at t-minus two hours 43
minutes and counting down for the launch
of Falcon 9 with dragon to the space
station as you see the dragon Launchpad
team has obviously arrived at the pallet
they got there shortly after t-minus
four hours open up the side hatch on
dragon got ready for the arrival of the
astronauts we saw the crew come up the
elevators walk over and enter dragon and
they're now getting situated inside the
capsule now the flight team is
monitoring data from Dragon they most
recently have completed a command and
telemetry check of the radio frequency
system on dragon through the tracking
and data relay satellite network that
looked to go well there are no issues
and work as we watch the astronauts
getting situated in their seats inside
the Dragon spacecraft the Falcon 9 team
is preparing for final checkouts and
propellant load those checkouts are due
to begin at t-minus two hours some 42
minutes from now when the launch crew
officially gets on console in the firing
room all systems on Falcon 9 are
currently go the range continues to be
green on the support side the areas
around the pad obviously clear except
for the folks doing the entry into the
capsule air and sea space are clear we
hear helicopter go by from time to time
the big concern is weather forecasts we
are continuing right now at a 50 percent
probability of violation of the weather
constraints the big concerns are going
to be the thick clouds precipitation
possibility of lightning I mentioned
earlier normally you get a strong sea
breeze from the ocean that pushes inland
and keeps the clouds from Central
Florida from building up
but today the sea breeze is fairly weak
so we expect the the thunderstorms will
get closer to launch pad we're also
checking downrange conditions if there's
a contingency splashdown of Dragon we're
looking at essentially the wave heights
lightning rain along the trajectory
right now it's marginal but it is still
we do expect that to improve slightly
during the day so fingers crossed there
that the downrange weather looks good
but right now at t-minus two hours 41
minutes as the clock continues to count
down all systems are go for launch
all right thanks John I and as we watch
Bob and Doug get buckled into their
seats I'm joined once again by SpaceX is
Jessica Jensen just to kind of walk
through everybody what may drag in a
21st century spacecraft so first off
thanks for coming in today I know you
got to come in for a launch that's
always tough we walk us through again
kind of dragon's life history I mean we
have one in a cleanroom pretty soon
right behind us walk us how we got to
where we are today to have Bob and Doug
climbing into that spacecraft sure so
SpaceX was founded to make life
multiplanetary that was why Elon started
the company back in 2002 and but you
know also when he found that the company
we were a very small company for several
years and so we had to look for
opportunities to you know hey how do you
go from being a small company to
actually putting people into orbit so
when NASA came out with the need to fly
cargo to and from the International
Space Station we jumped on that because
we said hey first not only is carrying
cargo to and from the space station cool
I bet we could actually then fly people
to the International Space Station and
hey for eight years now we've been
flying cargo yeah and then now we are
have transitioned over into flying crew
and cargo together so that's basically
been the evolution of Dragon and it's
been awesome and I know when we see
Falcon 9 we get to talk a lot about
reusability everyone is very familiar
with the the first stage coming back
down and yeah how cool that looks dragon
is also designed with some reusability
in fact you've flown dragon multiple
times or you've flown dragons multiple
times to the space station
how does reusability factor into dragons
lifecycle yeah so I'll let you talk a
little bit about both because I one
thing I think everyone always thinks
about reusability and hey it saves money
or that's great but reusability actually
improves your reliability so when we get
Falcons back and when we get dragons
either after one mission or multiple
mission we can do all these detailed
inspections on them and that's super
important because when you fly a vehicle
you can only have so many sensors on it
you can't put a sensor you know every
single inch of a rocket or a spacecraft
there's already way more than I think
anybody realized exactly but so you know
especially for Rockets that wind up in
the ocean
some people don't have any idea of what
they actually went through so the fact
that we get all the hardware back we
were able to inspect literally every
square inch of it and make small design
changes that actually improve
reliability for the whole fleet so even
though Bob and Doug are on a brand new
rocket and a brand new spacecraft that
those spacecraft are actually more
reliable based on the knowledge we've
learned from reusability we've walked
people through a lot of the new systems
on Dragon what are just some of the cool
things that are maybe beneath the
surface that people don't know about
with Dragon so I think one of the
coolest things is the autonomous docking
system and what that is is it's
basically we have you know GPS sensors
on dragon but then we also have cameras
and imaging sensors such as a lidar on
basically the nose cone or the front
part of Dragon as its approaching the
space station and all these sensors are
feeding data back to our flight computer
to say hey how far away am i from the
space station
what's my relative velocity to the space
station and then that feeds into the
flight computer which has algorithms
Rippa written by our engineers to say
okay based on how far away you are in
your rates here's how you fire the
thrusters to most effectively get to the
docking target I think that's just super
cool I mean we're all waiting for our
cars to drive ourselves to work and for
Bob and Doug that's exactly what it's
doing for them exactly and what I think
is so cool is the computer does this
just like flawlessly it's easy when I
tried to do it I failed miserably I
tried to dock drag in to the ISS three
times and I failed fourth time I got it
I will tell the public out there that on
our website we actually have a dragon
ISS simulator so you yourselves can try
and fire the thrusters you see how well
you do maybe I'm just a bad driver but I
think the flight computer does a really
good job I think we all had fun with it
all right
we are just starting to hear they're
gonna start up those calm checks with
Bob and Doug cd-r PLT con checks going
to listen in here they are loud and
clear
yeah I'll be loud and clear core loud
and clear umbilical contract complete
standby for a ground station contract
and again we're just listening in there
doing these comm check these
communication checks so Bob and Doug are
gonna do a series of these checkouts
with the teams on the ground both the
core here in Hawthorne and the launch
director out in Florida and they're
gonna be doing this over dragging the
ground and they're also going to be
doing it over the countdown net those
are the two main loops or nets that
you're gonna hear going out and they're
gonna be doing it through their
different communications paths we heard
them do through the tee dress or the
tracking data and relay satellites those
are those primary satellites that we're
going to be used to talk to Bob and Doug
throughout their flight and to send
commands to Dragon they'll also do it
through ground stations spacex has a
worldwide network of ground out
worldwide network of ground stations
that they're able to communicate with
the vehicle and that's what we'll be
using to get video inside the cabin of
Bob and Doug on their flight up so if
you tuned in the other day this is one
of the first things that they do once
they get inside the vehicle and this is
just to make sure all the communication
systems with the Dragon spacecraft with
the suits everything are working they're
able to talk to and hear everybody on
the ground
dragon spacex contact ground stations
great thank and load and clear core loud
and clear ground station contact
complete standby for teachers contract
and just a reminder you're hearing the
core that's the crew operations
responsible engineer that's if you've
followed NASA missions in the past
that's the Capcom position that is this
pretty much the singular voice that's
talking to the astronauts throughout
their flight that's a position based
here in Hawthorne California and you'll
also hear dragon SpaceX contract
teachers made that dragon loud and clear
cord low and clear teachers comm check
complete standby with contracts with MD
and LD in the launch configuration
dragon MD on counselin come check thanks
Jason mouth clear copy you loud and
clear glad to have you guys on board and
I stand by for contract on dragon
aground dragon MD dragon around come
check and B dragon loud and clear
MD loud and clear stand by for contracts
with LD dragon launch director I kept on
one call check good afternoon Mike loud
and clear I have you the same man good
afternoon stand by for my comm check on
dragon aground dragon SpaceX dragon the
ground table check SpaceX dragon loud
and clear I have you the same back to
Corey and dragon SpaceX it's good this
concludes our launch configuration
contracts report when ready for seat
rotation for section 2 of 4.1 zero zero
we are going to put that work copy
all right so all those communications
checks we're done successfully and you
could even see and it's so cool when we
get these views right inside the cabin
dragon in two decimal two we are ready
for seat rotation copy we will report
when initiating but you could see Doug
early using his right hand he has the
talk button built into the seat itself
so just again showing you all of the
different systems how the suit is
integrated into the seat and it's all
just one big circle for this whole
spacecraft so really cool to see those
comp checks live Jessica thank you so
much for joke walking us through some of
the really cool updates the upgrades did
you have any other cool stuff besides
let's see so I don't know if you guys
can see but we have the dragon cleanroom
here and one of the coolest things is it
is right on the main floor of our main
building so thousands of employees walk
by here all the time and get to see
dragon in its final processing before it
goes to the Cape on Wednesday the crew
one capsule was in here it looked almost
done it looks a little empty right now
but that's because that capsule went off
into our separate test facility for its
final propulsion checks so we do leak
checks and things there and we do that
in a separate facility just because it's
high-pressure testing and then the
vehicle will come back here get its
final thermal protection system put on
and then it will ship off the Cape
Canaveral and get ready to launch for
astronauts to the International Space
Station
I mean what's what's it like to see it
because when you see the first initial
pressure vessel it looks nothing like
the final thing so what's it like to
just kind of watch it go through and you
just see little bits get added on at it
and then the next thing you know it's a
whole spacecraft yeah I mean that's what
that's what's so amazing I'm so
impressed you know when you look at a
machine you're like how does this ever
get built how do people ever do this and
it really is just step by step one piece
at a time each piece has its critical
function and you get to watch that being
built right in front of your eyes every
day when you try to work a 60-hour seat
rotation copy and we just heard the C
rotations about to begin so Jessica
thank you so much cool facts about
dragon for everyone to listen in on and
we can see the seats start to rotate
pretty soon Bob and Doug will be in
their launch configuration and they'll
be ready to go
we can see the seats slowly start to
rotate again they're in this down
position just to make it easier to climb
in and out of dragon they'll rotate to
this launch position to put their backs
a little bit more parallel to the ground
it makes taking the g-force a little bit
easier for the quraan the way uphill but
most importantly positions those
touchscreens directly in front of them
which is just their gateway into dragon
dragons SpaceX seats here in the launch
position we're happy all right in
confirmation the seats are in the launch
position let's go down now to Gary in
Mission Control Houston where I know the
entire JSC team is standing by and ready
to see dragon take flight today
over to you Gary thanks Dan very much so
great to see good comm checks from Bob
and Doug and their seats have been
rotated into their launch position here
in Houston flight directors EBSCO ville
has polled Space Station flight
controllers and all systems are go for
launch from the space station side of
things
essentially the station's prepared for
Dragon to arrive 19 hour hours after
launch Chris Cassidy has completed his
preparations for Bob and Doug to arrive
he's got a chance to view some of the
broadcast it even said they were quote
looking sharp
flight controllers here will monitor the
countdown but really it's up to the
teams in Kennedy and Hawthorne to get us
to liftoff at this point so we want to
hear your comments as we continue to
countdown to launch so let's go to the
social desk now Tahira
thanks Gary so glad to hear that polls
are go at least on your end and just
hoping this weather just works out good
for today's launch
I mean people online are on the edge of
their seats we just checked numbers and
we are up to 1.1 million viewers right
now that's almost double when we checked
last time and right now we also have
Columbia South Carolina is leading the
viewership so interesting to see how
that changes let's take a broader look
at the conversation online with this
heat map of the United States now this
shows launch America mentions by state
over the past week and we have
California leading right now with the
most mentions and I'm very surprised I
really thought the
bass coast would take it home but let's
see how this changes over the course of
the broadcast and with that let's see
what y'all are posting online right now
guys I mean check out these outfits
absolutely love it
love to just see how people are making
things creative for this launch and
really making it their own putting their
personal touch on it let's take a look
at another oh we are back to the launch
America heat mentioned so let's see how
that changes over the course of this
broadcast but really fun to see those
photos online oh we have another space
pack guys these do not get old so please
use hashtag launch America on social
media right now it looks like we have
catched or not Boris who is ready for
his launch in the crew Dragon capsule I
just I love seeing the pet owners unite
for this mission so like I said
definitely use that hashtag we will be
looking for it during the show Murray
what's the latest at Kennedy
thanks to Hiro we are at t-minus two
hours 26 minutes 47 seconds and counting
from liftoff of the Falcon 9 from the
Kennedy Space Center here in Florida
carrying US astronauts Doug Hurley and
Bob Behnken you see them right now
aboard SpaceX's crewed dragon spacecraft
it's been a very exciting day so far the
crew has been up since about 8 o'clock
this morning as they prepare to head to
the International Space Station as part
of this demo - mission for NASA and as
we speak the astronauts as you saw our
inside dragon air and have completed
their comm checks so now they can
communicate with the teams here on the
ground and their seats have rotated up
right - they're reclined launch
positions allowing them to see and
access the display panel and now they
are about to they initiate their their
own suit leak checks to make sure that
their seat is in proper working
condition before liftoff and in just a
little bit at about t-minus one hour 55
minutes it could happen a little bit
sooner though we're running a little bit
ahead of schedule we will see the
closeout team begin to close the side
hatch in preparation for flight and
that's going to be one of the key visual
milestones on the timeline to liftoff
now we want to take you to a couple
special guests we have joining us they
are with Darrell nail at the OSB 2
viewing location NASA Administrator Jim
bridenstine and also Kennedy Space
Center Director Bob Cabana is there with
Darrell hi Darrell hi Murray that's
right we're in the fifth floor the
operations and support building here at
the Kennedy Space Center with a nice
view of launch complex 39 and the two
men that you mentioned are here to join
me to answer a few questions we're
excited to have them both here and they
are of course Bob Cabana the director of
the Kennedy Space Center and Jim Bryden
Stein administrator for NASA gentlemen
thanks again for making the time to be
here of course the big story right now
Jim is the weather so let's talk a
little bit about that we can see there's
some clouds building that was forecast
you took part in a weather briefing this
morning what do you know about the
weather and the decision that was made
to say hey let's let's give this another
shot today yeah so what godess last time
was the electricity in the atmosphere
and of course today there are in fact
buildups it doesn't look like there are
thunderstorms at this time but they are
expected the question is when do those
thunderstorms go away and when those
thunderstorms materialize where are they
located we are predicting about a 50/50
shot of going this time but given the
fact that we are in late May in Florida
where we have to take every shot we can
get so it's not likely that in a couple
of days it's going to be any better than
it is today so we're we are a go for
launch right now and we are hoping that
the weather will hold up we almost made
it on Wednesday and the trend is better
today than it was on Wednesday so we'll
see and I saw a forecast that said the
clearing is supposed to happen right
around three o'clock in the afternoon so
we're hoping that that lunch is at 3:20
to firing you know at the earliest three
o'clock at the latest 3:30 so depending
on when that happens will will either be
go or no-go but again we're gonna take
every shot we've got also watching the
downrange weather for a potential rescue
in case there were an abort that's right
so you know we have these staging areas
when we go from the first stage to the
second stage that's a higher risk
evolution we
to make sure that in the case we have to
exercise the launch abort at that point
that the weather is good and of course
that's off the coast of North Carolina
the big thing there is it's great that
we have a launch abort capability the
challenge is that launch abort
capability includes parachutes and with
parachutes you've got to make sure that
you've got the weather to come down if
there are thunderstorms or down burst or
high winds that's problematic for the
parachute system right and sea States as
well bouncing that capsule around in the
ocean above of course you're an
astronaut you know what it's like to hit
the reset button and do it all over
again
get into the spacecraft get ready to go
only to be told no we're not going to go
today we're gonna try it again
whoa what's that like and then and then
tell me about the mindset as you have to
kind of reset is there do you feel less
anxious you feel more comfortable with
the second time around you know Daryl
first off my last flight we counted down
to 18 seconds and didn't go manum you
get 18 seconds you're ready
the key is you know it's a training that
we go through all the repetition that we
do we practice everything including
scrubs and just because you didn't
launch doesn't mean you don't have
something to do so you got to go through
those back out procedures it's all done
very professionally then it was out of
the vehicle and into the Astro van back
to crew quarters in it we have a
positive attitude we got a good night's
rest and we went through it again it's
just it's a matter of doing your job and
these guys are well prepared you know
it's all part of what we do yeah they
stopped the count at 17 minutes but you
had just a few seconds and the truth is
the next night actually everything went
really better you know the weather was
bad the first time I was kind of glad we
scrubbed and we scrubbed for an issue
with the vehicle that they later sorted
out as it turned out we wouldn't had
enough' prop to rendezvous with the
Russian functional cargo block but you
know the next night it was just a
perfectly smooth launch count everything
just went like clockwork and it set the
stage for an awesome mission I think you
told the press before you walked out I
think you were over there at astronaut
crew quarters we're going today I'm
wondering though where's the source of
that confidence coming by I just got a
feeling you know you gotta have a
positive attitude you know I watched a
lot of weather down here support and
shuttle missions and I'm hoping that
those clouds
or that I 95 corridor that the Indian
River keeps some west of west of us and
that stuff that's building offshore is
far enough off that we can stay stay in
an open window here at the Cape good
well we got your positive vibe going and
we appreciate that Jim when you were
down in the astronaut crew quarters and
when they were suiting up you got a
second chance to visit with the
astronauts kind of tell us about that
and what was their demeanor what was
their mood today so again they seemed
loose they were loose last time they're
loose this time they're definitely ready
to go they're excited they've been
wanting to go for a long time now you
know what was I'll tell you one thing
that I thought was a little interesting
is you know Bob Behnken was making fun
of Doug Hurley because I'm Doug's last
flight they scrubbed five times before
launching on the sixth time so Bob
Behnken seems to think that Doug Hurley
is the problem is in this case but to
see them joking about that as they're
getting suited up ready to go yes there
they're there they're trained they're
ready but they're also loose and that's
good to see because because they're
gonna have to be on their game when when
we launch these guys are pretty
impressive Doug Hurley and Bob Behnken I
mean Doug Hurley an incredible pilot Bob
Behnken he's got a PhD in mechanical
engineering test engineer and myself in
the Air Force
way and you're in your assessment why
are these guys the right stuff well this
is a test flight and and you know we got
we have great astronauts that are you
know chemists we have great astronauts
that are botanists we have really
talented and diverse a very very diverse
astronaut corps in general but this is a
test flight and for a test flight what
do you want you want test pilots you
want people that for a living they have
made a living flying new things that
have never been flown before and you
know Bob Behnken and Doug Hurley are the
the two people that you would want in a
test flight and that's exactly what this
is Bob you're a pilot too you want to
weigh in on Doug Hurley he seems like
you know he's he's got the right
mentality
he's a naval aviator a Marine pilot a
test pilot he's I'm all-in he's a great
guy
and and tell me a little bit about in
terms of the Kennedy Space Center right
so
you've been here since 2007 right 2008
2008 sorry off by one year 2011 the
Atlantis came to a wheel stop I grew up
here my dad worked for NASA my uncle was
a contractor when that wheel stop
happened the next day my uncle got the
layoff notice right 30 60 days it was
depressing we talked about thousands of
people laid off super-depressing
Atlantis landed on a Thursday on Friday
2000 contractors got pink slips and
walked out the door yet they work on
that vehicle that was the best vehicle
we ever flew the cleanest that's a
dedication of the workforce here right
so it didn't take me back to that time
you called it a depressing time you know
the fact that the shuttle program was
something that the government completely
had ownership of and paid for now we're
moving into this Commercial Crew which
you've overseen making that transition
and tell me about that nine years in
which we made that move obviously
everybody was really attached to the
shuttle I mean it was our history for
thirty years and did an awesome job the
Hubble Space Telescope all the
satellites that deployed building the
International Space Station but when I
first got here I told everybody the
shuttle program is going to end we got
we have to start preparing for our
future and and nobody wanted that to
hear that but how many times in your
life do you get to define what you want
your future to be and we set out on this
bold goal of trying to turn KSC into a
multi-user spaceport supporting both
government and commercial operations and
I've got a very persistent team they
worked extremely hard and through a
number of agreements you know we were
able to make it happen and this is the
future commercial spaceflight you know
the administrator says that all the time
we want to establish a commercial
environment in low-earth orbit so that
we can focus on the hard job of
exploring beyond our home planet to
establish that presence in our solar
system beyond planet Earth established a
sustained presence on the moon get to
Mars establish a presence there we can't
do that if we're locked here in
low-earth orbit and Commercial Crew with
both SpaceX and Boeing that's the
beginning of a whole new era of
spaceflight alright very good
a quick question we got of course a
special guest coming back today the
president of United States plans on
being here
Jim you took him around the first time
around how did that go I think I saw a
picture on Twitter he signed some space
hardware that's right so so he took a
look at the Orion crew capsule of course
the Orion for Artemus one is ready to go
and he signed you know a piece of
hardware that will fly on the crew
capsule for Artemus too so that's kind
of and not just him but the first lady
and the vice-president and the second
lady they all signed it so so their
names are gonna fly around the moon on
Artemis too which is exciting but I just
want to give Colonel Cabana
a compliment here because he did bring
this spaceport through a very difficult
time and now it is a a multi-use
spaceport and we do have commercial and
we have in fact even international
launches here and now we're going to
have commercial crew launches bob has
done a wonderful job transforming this
spaceport that's why we're doing
Commercial Crew NASA wants to be one
customer of many customers we want to
have numerous providers that are
competing on cost innovation safety
driving down costs increasing access but
even better today when I took this job
just a few short years ago you know our
budget at NASA was around 19 billion
dollars the budget requests that
President Trump gave us for next year is
25 billion dollars we are in a great
great position because the president is
committed to space exploration of course
he's committed to the space force we
haven't had this much support for space
since John F Kennedy and we've got
bipartisan support everybody wants to
see the Artemis program be successful
everybody wants to see not just the next
man but the first woman on the moon and
that's what we're building here that's Q
the key to it all is that bipartisan
support and of course what the work that
Bob's been doing here you can see the
commercial activity all around this
place we're gonna get to some questions
on social media real quick that our you
know our audience wants to find out so
the first question is from James on
Twitter and he asks what is the hardest
part of going to space we're gonna have
to give that question to Bob well there
are you know nothing's hard if you
prepare for it and what we are afraid of
is a is stuff we don't have knowledge
about and that's what we do
when we learn how to be astronauts we
train okay you spent a long time as an
astronaut candidate learning you spent a
long time preparing for a mission for an
International Space Station mission
training around the world on all the
different modules and everything you
know it's like two and a half years of
training before you get on orbit for
that time to actually do your work so
I'd have to say the hardest part is the
preparation for it but you are so
prepared when you go you just have total
confidence you know that you are very
well trained for what you're going to do
you have an outstanding team on the
ground supporting you and that is so
important to have that ground support as
you climb into that vehicle you know
that they have done their very best to
ensure your safety and in a successful
mission but after that it's piece of
cake except no simulator on earth can
prepare you for what those guys are
gonna feel it's better than a catch that
off in your career maybe one day I'll
get to try the commercialization effort
means we want everybody to be able to
fly into space absolutely that's a great
point about preparation because that's
not the highly visible part the launch
is and so it's good to know that all
that preparation leads to that
confidence by the way just an update
operationally they're getting ready to
close the hatch door you can see on your
screen there the the workers there are
getting ready to get that closed and
working on working on that right there
with Doug Doug Hurley and Bob bacon on
the inside of crew dragon our next
question is from Malthus on Twitter and
he asks what kind of operations will the
astronauts do between the liftoff and
docking with the International Space
Station I know you pay a lot of
attention Jim to the operations
especially if this mission but do you
know about that so there's a number of
things the first thing that they have to
do is of course we've got a number of
burns to get in phase with the
International Space Station we've got
some boost burns as well we're talking
about you know operating the rocket
engine to to get in alignment with the
space station but I'll tell you the
biggest thing that we need the
astronauts to do once they get on orbit
and before they dock is rest we need
them to eat we need them to rest we need
them to be prepared for that docking
once they are in the range of the
International Space Station they're
going to start moon
during the spacecraft themselves not
automatic but they're going to do it
themselves they are in fact test pilots
and as test pilots they will test fly
this vehicle to make sure that it
operates as advertised and of course
then they will dock with the
International Space Station and a unique
capability here is its automatic
rendezvous and automatic docking and so
we're going to be able to see that for
the first time as well that's going to
be exciting to see thank you for sharing
that with us
Jim Brian Stein administrator of NASA
Bob Cabana director of the Kennedy Space
Center thank you both for joining us and
we're gonna send it back to Murray in
the studio all right thanks a lot Darryl
and mr. Brydon Stein and mr. cabana for
joining us you can see some clouds
starting to gather over launch complex
39a we're keeping a close eye on weather
again 50 50 percent chance of launching
today we just got to see what the
weather's gonna do a little bit ago we
heard the crew complete their comm
checks live on the air we saw their
seats rotate that helps get them into a
little bit more comfortable position for
the g-forces during launch and more
importantly it helps them be in a better
position to interact with the screens in
front of them they completed their suit
leak checks we saw during the interview
just a few minutes ago the hatch begin
to close and so inside the white room
there the pad closeout team is in there
I'm still doing some work that that
hatch closes you know it's not as simple
as just closing a car door there's a
process to seal it and check it and make
sure that everything is sealed properly
right Lauren yeah that's correct if they
haven't already started one thing that
will be coming up next is the leak check
what they'll do is they'll attach a
piece of ground support equipment they
don't have it in their hands right now
so it looks like it hasn't started yet
there it is you can see it there the
closeout number number five it's already
attached to the side hatch mechanism and
what they'll do is they're essentially
checking for the leak rate and they'll
hold pressure there for a few minutes
and then track that change in pressure
over time to make sure that it's within
bounds making sure that you don't have
any issues with those o-rings there that
are holding that pressure
and so once they complete that leak
check
they will then do what is the called the
installation or the final installation
of the s pep or side pressure
equalization plug that's basically a
plug that once the capsule splashes down
what you'll do is actually remove that
and what it does is equalize this
pressure across the hatch so once that
thing is plugged in you know that
everything is is super tight and that
you shouldn't have any leaks on orbit
one of the other things that I think is
pretty cool about dragon you can kind of
see them on the edges there are some of
the windows I know that dragon started
out as cargo
it was cargo dragon you have your cargo
version and before you moved on to the
crew dragon version but you even had
windows on the cargo version can you
explain kind of why that was yeah the
very first cargo dragon that we ever had
that we ever launched had a window over
the hatch of the side hatch and the
reason we did that is we always
envisioned dragon to ultimately be a
crewed vehicle so even in the beginning
for the first the very first vehicle we
ever made which carried didn't even
really carry much cargo we put that
window there and it to us symbolizes
what dragon's purpose has been all along
you know taking those steps starting off
with the the CRS program and resupplying
the space station with with experiments
and and food and crew provisions for the
astronauts on boards and now putting our
own astronauts astronauts in our own
vehicle it's that natural progression to
what we were aiming for the whole time
and Leland what's your take on the
touchscreen technology we saw a little
bit about that obviously this is a very
different kind of look than what we saw
during Space Shuttle you know it's the
future I mean we had our LCD displays
and we had lots of buttons to press and
you know valves and switches and I think
this this new technology will allow us
to get through procedures much more fat
you know much much faster because we had
you know paper flight data file that
we're having to turn to different pages
and get to things and I think this will
make it much more efficient to go
through your functions in your pursue
with the touchscreens and I think you
know having the gloves being able to you
know touch the screens and work within
the gloves everything's kind of sleek
and efficient you know there's not a lot
of wires and things hanging off and
there are new boards you can see there
any boards on their left knees so that's
for some extra mobile notes and things
there's some commissary we are ready for
the briefing when you are ready of
coffee and we just heard confirmation on
the loops that the hatch is closed so
that is a little bit ahead of schedule
we are motivated to go today okay on the
weather we still have some rain showers
moving through the area but we do have a
reasonable opportunity today so we are
proceeding into the counts we are going
to take a look at both pad and ascent
track weather at t-minus one hour and
thirty minutes and the next decision
point will be prior to prop loads okay
we copy and on the vehicle health front
both f9 and dragon Health's remains
nominal with no items nope
so we just heard the weather is still
iffy oh dude thank you
the weather is still iffy concludes the
post ingress brief report when ready for
contracts with Falcon 9 operators we are
ready for the f9 upgrade
coppy expect that shortly so when we
hear that chatter pick back up we're
going to quiet right down so that you
can listen in to that along with us but
we just heard them discussing the
weather briefly still keeping an eye on
that but the next decision point is
going to be before prop load so we're
gonna press forward for now and then
reevaluate on before they start fueling
the rocket but in the meantime it sounds
like Falcon 9 and crew dragon are
healthy so the vehicle is in good shape
right it sounds like kind of a little
bit of a repeat from Wednesday that were
just keeping an eye on the weather at
this point you can see on their left
legs well in that previous American
spacex contracts with after 9:00 you can
expect it in about one to two minutes
dragons ready all right on their left
legs there they have the satchels that
are strapped to their legs inside are
some crew provisions including these
tablets that you see that they have
displayed there you say Lauren those are
tablets versus just me Boyd said you can
write on tablets or inside for their
inside okay okay
and so when would they pull those
tablets out to use them during the
mission Wow yeah while in orbit okay and
I don't know if it's coming if this the
background noise is coming through
over-the-air but we hear the rain really
picking up outside the studio here so
kind of wondering if Bob and Doug are
hearing the sounds of the rain clouds
opening up over the pad looks like
they're it's still kind of patchy out
there but again we were following some
thunderstorms that look like they may be
making their way over here it kind of
looks like it's raining from that view
it's kind of it's a little bit hard to
tell through the haze
all right lunch launch is now just over
two hours away - here you are there with
the social teams now that the hatch is
closed and the rains picking up and all
kinds of exciting things are going on
right now as we countdown and get into
the last two hours of the count I bet
things are getting pretty interesting on
social media hey Lauren I mean yes they
are so many different things are going
on right now and I think people online
are just wondering what's gonna happen
with today's mission
I have TweetDeck open right now and it
is just scrolling with the conversation
of people around the nation talking
about today's launch attempt we also
just checked viewership and we are now
up to 1.4 million people watching this
live broadcast so really hope things
look good with weather and on that note
let's take a look of some of the things
being said on Twitter right now so it
looks like we just have some more future
astronauts I really love seeing the
young generation just getting mobilized
getting excited about today's mission
looks like we've also got some Godspeed
and safe travels for both astronauts
today really do wish them the best of
luck on the second attempt hope it
happens some throwback photos all from
people visiting NASA sinners and also
just let's do this I love this can-do
attitude and I just love seeing that
people are still keeping the energy
alive for today's launch so there were
obviously some disappointing reactions
to Wednesday's scrub but let's take a
look at how people are getting excited
for today's attempt let's roll
I mean how fun is that video I think I
will definitely have to attempt the worm
after this but just really glad to see
everyone in good spirits leading into
today's second launch attempt and I
really hope everybody will have
something to smile about and with that
let's head back to Lauren Lori thanks to
here it looks like people are pretty
stoked about today's attempt please
continue
to join the conversation by using the
hashtag launched America across all the
social media channels yeah I love seeing
I really love seeing the little kids get
excited I know my my three-year-old is
super excited she's got an astronaut
sleeping bag and she loves to climb in
it yeah it's the the body of the bag is
a spacesuit and then the head is empty
where they were the pillow is so when
she gets inside it looks like she's got
a spacesuit on so she loves it that's
the inspiration for that next generation
of explorers gonna take Doug and Bob's
place one day and I think we have some
people out there that are so interested
in our conversation about the worm and
the meatball that they've created
something called the worm ball okay I
was checking my emails you like I
emailed you guys the worm ball and I was
like what is this I don't I'm having a
hard time seeing it but what is the worm
ball so it's a it's a NASA meatball
which is you know what it should be
yes okay look
okay there all right thank you I need it
so they took the angular NASA logo and
put in the worm inside of the meatball
can you can you live with that Lauren
you know what that's a beautiful
compromise I'll take it and there is
another live look at launch complex 39a
and we have had the opportunity to share
with you a lot about the spacex crew
dragon sitting on top of falcon 9 a lot
about the crew themselves and the
significance of today as the official
return we hope of human launch
capability to American shores but we
would be remiss if we did not explain
why this pad 39a is hallowed ground
[Music]
many of NASA's story missions began
their daring journey from the exact same
spot on earth launch complex 39a at the
Kennedy Space Center this massive
structure of steel and concrete has
cradled rockets and guided each on their
fiery ascent to space for over 50 demos
there can be no launch without a launch
pad and this hallowed ground has a
history greater than any other having
evolved and been reshaped for each new
era of spaceflight it's alive with a
heartbeat as strong as the first
Launchpad 39a came to life under the
direction of project engineer Harry may
as NASA ramped up its efforts to achieve
an unprecedented calling why some say
the I choose this and they may well ask
my climb high in 1962 earthmoving
machines sculpted its massive pyramid
base to a height of 40 feet then
concrete was poured to hold it in place
to launch the world's first moon rocket
engineers cut a flame trench nearly the
length of two football fields down the
middle of the mound it was in line with
heat-resistant bricks to deflect seven
and a half million pounds of a birth
rattling thrust first felt on Apollo 8
less than a year later Apollo 11
launched from pad 39a and hundreds of
millions of people around the world
watched as it landed on the moon
three days later nearly a decade after
this Apollo era 39a again took center
stage with a new one-of-a-kind
spacecraft this space shuttle billions
of pounds of additional steel for
service structures transformed the look
but not the purpose human spaceflight
in all 82 space shuttles blasted off
from 39a until the very last day - ten
nine eight one zero and liftoff the
final liftoff of Atlantis shoulders of
the Space Shuttle America will continue
the bridge with the fleet retired
demolition crews removed the shuttle era
hardware to clear the way for NASA's
monumental decision to lease this
historic launch site to the private
company SpaceX today it's sleek and
modern design supports a family of
rockets that has advanced the commercial
age of American space flight now 50
years after it first sent humans to the
moon this historic spaceport stands
ready for the next wave of human
exploration
[Music]
and we're looking live again at pad 39a
we're looking at the pad closeout team
you can identify them by their numbers
there and we heard confirmation of the
hatch being closed just a few minutes
ago so again things a little bit ahead
of schedule
when I say ahead of schedule I don't
mean the launch time is changing I just
mean on some of the specific milestones
in the timeline those times are a little
bit flexible but that launch window
remains instantaneous at 3:22 this
afternoon
and Leland you know we just saw a piece
about the history of pad 39a vision all
stations chief engineer and countdown
one fork object with the crew we're
gonna pause for that contract a good
nine guidance navigation and control
dragon GNC on countdown one contact GNC
dragon we have Devon clear GNC loud and
clear stand by for comm check by the
propulsion engineer dragon problem
countdown one concert top dragon loud
and clear problems and clear stand by
for contact with the avionics engineer
dragon avionics on countdown one comm
check avionics dragon loud and clear
avionics loud and clear stand by for
contact by ground segment engineer
dragon ground segment icons on long Tong
six ground segment dragon loud and clear
gurgling loading please stand by for Tom
check for lost control
dragon launch control and countdown one
Tom Cech Hantz control dragon loud and
clear lost control loud and clear stand
by for contract by the chief engineer
dragon chief engineer on countdown one
comm check
chief engineer dragon we've got - loud
and clear Bala chief engineer loud and
clear this completes the Falcon 9
responsible engineering context and we
just saw a thumbs-up from Doug Hurley we
listened to a series of comms comms
checks there and so everything chief
engineer on dragon the ground and clear
on dragging the ground loud and clear
well good luck and let's see if the rain
clears up that sentiment is shared by
all here do it copy that
so Bob and Doug along with the launch
teams and all of the rest of America
hoping the rain clears up here but as
far as comments checks ago everything
sounded pretty normal pretty nominal
there so we're just waiting on the
weather to clear up but again there's a
live look at launch complex 39a the site
of 82 Space Shuttle missions where they
began and of course Apollo the first
mission to the moon Apollo 11 lifted off
from 39a and Leland you were just five
years old when that happened she's back
there Orion Lauren I was five and I was
the antenna engineer during the
broadcast I was the kid standing behind
the black-and-white Sylvania television
holding the rabbit ears and my dad said
move to the left look to the right and I
was trying to look around the television
to see what was going on but I said no
no stay there so I never actually saw
the actual landing on the moon Neil and
Buzz walking on the moon and the next
day all the friend my friends in my
community were like he ain't gonna be an
astronaut we just had this momentous
thing I said no I didn't see it I want
to be Arthur Ashe because Arthur Ashe
trained five blocks down the street
where I grew up and my dad talked about
is his excellence is perseverance his
athleticism and so it wasn't until I got
to NASA working as an engineer at NASA
Langley that a friend of mine said you'd
be a great astronaut and I'm just
laughed at him and I didn't feel the
application out but another friend of
mine got in and Charlie Kamara and I
said if he can become an astronaut I can
become so I applied the next year and I
got in in the 1998 class and I think
about this again storied legacy pad 39a
I was there in 2008 and 2009 space
shuttle Atlantis the last one they came
in with Doug and the rest of the crew
and it's just an amazing time see this
new era with Lauren with your SpaceX
crew dragon about to take off I never
heard that story it's it's so cool that
you know you do have a lot of these kids
that are watching today who have never
seen a flight a human spaceflight from
KSC before
and this is their first time and I'm
trying to remember back you know I grew
up in the shuttle era and I grew up in
Los Angeles and I remember sometimes
when the shuttle would land at Edwards
Air Force Base you'd hear those sonic
booms in school and and we all just knew
oh that's the Space Shuttle it was just
the thing we just knew about that and it
didn't make me sad that there's a like
an entire generation of kids who didn't
grow up with that experience and I'm
just so proud that you know today
hopefully we get to provide that for
kids and hopefully have more and more of
these launches to the point where it
becomes routine hopefully never boring
but routine and there's talent in every
zip code to have to make sure that every
kid is has the opportunity to do these
types of things if they believe in
themselves and we give them the right
tools that they can use to be in STEM
fields and you know we have a very
diverse group of people up here working
together and get Bob and Doug off safely
and I think more people that see this
type of diversity will have a chance to
say I can do that too absolutely and you
know we have a lot of kids watching
today and we have an opportunity to hear
from another really awesome role model
especially for the little girls in the
audience so we want to throw it over to
Gary in Houston to talk to a very
special astronaut standing by there hi
Gary
hi Marie I have the distinct pleasure of
being joined by one of NASA's
record-setting astronauts and a recent
resident aboard the space station
Christina cook Christina thank you for
joining us it's great to be with you
today
Christina we're coming up on 20 years of
continuous human presence on the
International Space Station and you were
one of those humans what's it like to
see a new milestone like this launch
unfold after so much history already
you're right so much history indeed and
it's just been great to watch all unfold
I think for me the most exciting thing
is how NASA is not only innovating in
what we do it's you know exploring the
universe pushing the boundaries getting
knowledge on the space station bringing
it back to earth for benefits here but
in how we do it we're innovating in the
implementation of those goals and of our
mission and what that means is that
bringing in the private sector bringing
in a commercial space at
me for low-earth orbit I mean space is
going to be more accessible and more
innovative and it's just an awesome new
era of history to be able to witness you
hold the record for the longest single
stay by a female astronaut in space
what's it like living aboard for so long
well it is truly a privilege every
single day I have to I have to say it's
a beautiful thing to look down on the
earth and to be able to kind of
contribute to a space program that you
yourself have held in such high regard
your entire life I would say that the
biggest challenge going into sort of
those longer times is remaining vigilant
the engineers make it so easy to live on
board the space station sometimes you
forget you're actually surrounded by
such a hostile environment so remaining
vigilant both day to day to have that
appreciation then that you wake up with
every day and then also being vigilant
knowing that things could take a turn
for the worse at anytime and you have to
be ready to react to that so it's a
great privilege but it also comes with
great responsibility you came to NASA
after the days of the shuttle program
and you flew on the Russian Soyuz what
does it mean to have this private
capability to fly astronauts to the
station well I think it's just a great
innovation in terms of our partnerships
you know when we started out it was
individual countries pursuing suspects
pleurae ssin we brought in the
International aspect of it and now we're
really folding in that commercial aspect
bringing the innovation of all of our
American industrial power and
recognizing that the more partnerships
we have the more accessible the more
innovative Space Exploration can be so
it's an awesome time and it brings with
it so much more capability into the
program as well so it's not only how
we're doing it but it's what it brings
we're looking forward to having this
transportation from private companies
how does it help you do your job in
space you know I think one concept that
we have in NASA for safety and to
mitigate risk is called dissimilar
redundancy and here now we're bringing
up a sole second way of getting crew to
the International Space Station and
getting cargo last minute cargo so we're
increasing how much science we can do
onboard the space station by twofold
we're increasing how we can you know our
options for getting items up stowage
items supplies provisions science
experiments so we're really just banking
on the extra
doesn't see to make the programs that
much more robust we're watching Bob and
Doug go through the final phases of
preparing for this launch what's going
through your mind so close to liftoff
it's such a great day indeed you know
it's interesting because I think it's
not so much what is going through your
mind but what's not going through your
mind you know you're not thinking about
all the things could go wrong you're
thinking about enabling success by doing
what you've been trained to do one of
the things we have is that on launch day
astronauts are sometimes the most calm
people in the room and I found that to
be true on my launch day too
I think it's kind of this career
culmination of everything you've learned
everything you've dreamed up and you
know that it's coming together in that
day and that you're gonna finally do
what you're prepared to do execute the
mission and it just really brings a
sense of calm and readiness NASA
astronaut Christina Cooke always an
honor to hear from you thank you great
to be with you well once Bob and Doug
arrived at the station NASA astronaut
Chris Cassidy will be ready to welcome
them onboard so in anticipation of their
launch he had this message for them
hello everyone I'm astronaut Chris
Cassidy commander of expedition 63
onboard the International Space Station
flying 250 miles above the earth like
you I'm excited about today's launch and
the possibilities it will bring to
America into the world but also I'm very
excited that two close friends will be
arriving and joining the crew I had the
privilege of flying with Doug Hurley on
both of our first Shuttle missions back
in 2009 together we came to the
International Space Station and helped
construct the amazing facility that it
is today although this will be my first
mission with Bob it was my honor to
follow him as a chief of the office when
he left back in 2015 to begin training
for this amazing mission personally I've
been very fortunate to fly in two
different spacecraft
launching from America on the shuttle
and most recently launching from
Kazakhstan in the Soyuz but I can't tell
you how exciting it is to know that
we're once again launching Americans
from the coast of Florida and finally
here's a story I'd like to share with
you back in 1981 John Young and Bob
Crippen launched on space shuttle
Columbia the very first space shuttle
flight marking the last time we flew
Americans on a brand-new vehicle with
them they flew an American flag
representing America's technical prowess
30 years later that same flag was flown
to the International Space Station this
flag remains here today waiting for Bob
and Doug
[Music]
our flag means so many things to our
country and this small piece of America
represents what we'll be able to achieve
together we'll never stop exploring and
so Bob and Doug can take this very
special flag home to earth where it
awaits its next journey to the cosmos in
a few years if first Orien crew will
take this flag with it around the moon
all of this starts today
I'll be watching outside the window
along with everyone else in America and
around the world I can't wait to look
out the window and see my friends on
close approach go Falcon 9 go dragon and
go Bob and Doug I'll see you soon and
there again is a live look at launch
complex 39a at Kennedy Space Center in
Florida or we are t-minus one hour 41
minutes 58 seconds and counting from
liftoff of the Falcon 9 rocket carrying
crew dragon with astronauts Bob bank Bob
Behnken and Doug Hurley strapped inside
we can see some raindrops on the screen
there it looks like rain coming down at
the pad but we're still monitoring
weather and it sounds like there's going
to be another decision point before they
start fueling the Falcon 9 rocket which
is scheduled to happen at about t-minus
35 minutes so we just heard a little bit
about where they're headed if the
weather cooperates today to the
International Space Station
Leland you've been there twice and I
know just from what you've told us it's
it's this Leviathan in space and the
sight of so much important work and
partnerships happening right Chris
Cassidy's up there floating in the
Columbus laboratory that I installed or
our team of us installed on sts-122 and
I think about you know using this
robotic arm that was made in Canada the
European Space Agency built the Columbus
laboratory and my job was to use that
arm and attach it to the International
Space Station and as it was getting
closer and closer the motion just
stopped and I'm like what is going on
and therefore ready to laugh indicators
that have a very slight spring force
that I was moving so
slowly with the hand controller the
translational hand controller that that
that spring force stalled out the motion
and Peggy Whitson was behind me and she
said Leland whether some commentary
weather update I think go ahead hey Doug
we're still waiting for a weather update
expected at eighteen Zulu therefore the
next assessment will be closer to the
propellant load time we are currently no
go and launch weather but we are showing
and expected clear of 1830 judith okay
cap al thanks for the update so we just
heard if if they were to launch right
now the weather would be no-go however
it sounds like there may be an
opportunity if the weather clears as it
sounds like they expect it may so again
we're gonna we're gonna keep listening
as we continue talking if we start to
hear any kind of chatter especially if
it's about the weather we're gonna do
our best to quiet down so that we don't
step on that and everyone can hear it
along with us but Leland you were just
talking about the work on station and
and Peggy Whitson was getting ready to
tell you something so the Columbus
laboratory is stalled out is about to be
attached and there are 10,000 people
waiting their job security depended on
me installing this thing properly right
and Peggy said Leland push just a little
bit harder on the hand controller and
all for ready to latch indicators went
green and I was like yes and that was
our primary mission objective but that
paled in comparison to what happened
next Peggy invited us over to dinner in
the Russian segment and we had this meal
with people from all over the world
Russian German French African American
Asian American this diversity that we
talked about earlier were up there
breaking bread at 17,500 miles per hour
while listening to Sade's smooth
operator
[Music]
Wow actually changed the song to from
smooth operator to arm operator so you
see and Leland you actually we were in
another tape segment when you got a text
from Drew Feustel can you can you share
that with us yeah drew voice Allah and
just sent me a text saying that uh the
families say hello to all who are
watching and thank the nation in the
world for their support and interest and
Chris Ferguson just actually sent me a
text see was the commander on sts-135
and one of my classmates from the 1998
class and he says where to go Scott
speed on crew dragon it's great to hear
those words of support thank you guys
for watching and everybody following
along at home I mean the the Cova 19
situation has been just a just a tough
time for people stuck inside home
schooling their kids still trying to do
their jobs and so it's it's really cool
to be able to to watch this happening
and we see the pad closeout team it
looks like they're getting ready or that
like they've left the the white room and
they've already come down the crew
access arm so they are getting ready to
leave the pad now and we are going to go
now to the operations and support
building to where Darryl nail is
standing by with NASA's chief of staff
to talk to us a little bit about some of
NASA's ambitions beyond the
International Space Station and its work
with the Commercial Crew program Darryl
yeah that's right we're here in the
mission briefing room at the top
operations and support building here
where there's a lot of important people
that are gathering to watch the launch
here and one of those people's not me by
the way one of those people that is
important is Gabe Sherman NASA's chief
of staff we appreciate you being here
hey thanks for having me Darryl you got
kind of the insight of what's coming
down the pike here at NASA so of course
today is Commercial Crew and we're
focused on that seeding the commercial
market but what's off in the horizon for
NASA well I'll just tell you it's an
incredibly exciting time to be at NASA
and you know this I mean you're here
every day but whatever you think about
what we're doing
with Commercial Crew you know in the
horizon in July we're launching Mars
perseverance which is just gonna be an
incredible incredible thing for us you
look at the end of this year you know
SLS the largest rocket in the world is
going through testing right now going
through green run testing and then we're
hoping maybe by the end of the year we
could even get it right out here to the
Cape which would be just an incredible
achievement for our team so there is no
shortage of things to be excited about
it NASA right now it feels like
everything is really starting to happen
here recently with everything that you
just mentioned and if we get that first
Artemis launch that could be right
around the corner as well you know we're
looking at I think late 2021 is what
we're looking for and so you think about
SLS potentially moving through it from
the green run to the Cape you've got a
Ryan finishing up its last little bit of
testing it moved from plum Brook earlier
this year our station up there in Ohio
down to KSC so we're looking at checking
it out throughout next year and
hopefully we'll have the first
integrated flight of SLS and Orion at
the end of 2021 and I'm telling you that
that is going to be a moment there'll be
a thunderous boom right here at the
Kennedy Space Center
so with Mars as the end goal how do how
does all of this get to that end point
you bet no and I think that's what's so
important about the Artemis program
right our long-term vision is to get to
Mars but you know when you think about
Artemis everything that we're doing at
the moon is helping us learn prove out
capabilities and technologies work
through the right mission durations
understand how we utilize the resources
of the Moon potentially to go further on
to Mars so the technology the science
the exploration architecture that we're
putting together each and every piece of
it is helping us learn a little bit more
prove out a little bit more so we can
take that next giant leap to Mars and so
everything that we're doing at the moon
helps prepare us to move on to Mars how
about the activity in low-earth orbit
like Commercial Crew which is happening
today how does that help us for missions
to the moon yeah I think anytime you're
launching humans you're learning right
and you're taking what you've learned
and you're you're moving it forward to
the next to the next mission but I think
it's really about the business case if
you think about what Commercial Crew is
it's NASA moving from owning and
operating hardware to buying a service
right and if you remember just a few
weeks ago and
awarded three contracts on the human
landing system to commercial companies
and so we're hoping that we moved to a
day we're actually buying a service to
get our astronauts back and forth to the
moon
so actually enabling the commercial
market to go from low-earth orbit all
the way out to lunar orbit and so
Commercial Crew is a great proving
ground for that helps us prove out that
business case build those partnerships
and then we get a feed forward to the
moon so it's a it means a lot this means
a lot as we move out it's really
exciting when you talk about the
Commercial Crew the commercial
commercial aspect going to the moon and
those partners um they're gonna be
studying those Landers to see if they
are viable for NASA
yeah working through a tremendous
process of with with the commercial
providers and NASA engineers going
through initial designs right now
looking at at the capabilities that
they've proposed and then trying to make
decisions on which which landing system
goes early in 2024 which landing systems
are better prepared for sustainability
out into the later 20s and so that is
going to be an ongoing process
throughout this year and moving into
next so it's gonna be really exciting to
kind of see what what comes out is hey
this is the lander that's going to take
the first woman and the next man to the
moon in 2024
all right so different than the time of
Apollo we went to the moon and that
program ultimately came to an end the
idea here though is to try to create
some sustainability and sustainability
you can get to sustainability if you
have reusability right and that's that's
what we're seeing with Commercial Crew
for sure but whenever you think about
our human landing system you're looking
at a system that we put out there at the
moon once we get to sustainability and
it's going back and forth taking
multiple trips to the lunar surface back
up to Gateway which you're familiar with
this kind of our smaller space station
we're going to put in orbit around the
moon so we are building an architecture
but is going to enable reusability at
the moon Apollo never had that and so
whenever you think about driving down
cost and increasing access reusability
sustainability are critical so you get
to see everything from a very high level
at NASA what's it like for you
personally I'm curious to be here at the
Kennedy Space Center to watch a launch
and just just see this amazing facility
where all of this
activity happened yeah I think sometimes
people think since I work at NASA I'm
around this stuff all the time I'm not
right I don't get to come down here
nearly as often as I'd like so it's just
as exciting for me as it is for anybody
else in this room when you think about
all the hard work that our team has put
in to get us to this day to actually
come down and be a part of it with them
I was just in it just it's just
overwhelming and incredible so we're
just a little bit excited all right Gabe
Sherman NASA's chief of staff we
appreciate you joining us today and
enjoy the launch I certainly know you
will if we were able to get that one off
we're gonna toss this back now to
Hawthorne California joining us now is
SpaceX this large black more to discuss
SpaceX's future ambitions to visit the
moon and mars thanks for joining us
again today for a second round could you
tell us just a little bit about your
background and what you do here at space
at SpaceX yeah well I'm in charge of
entry and landing for starship which is
SpaceX is next rocket Falcon and before
that I worked for many years on the same
thing for Falcon so hopefully today
you'll see another one of those landings
or unship awesome and speaking of that
what role does reusability play in
getting people to the Moon and Mars in
the future well it's really all about
making human spaceflight affordable and
what you want for that is a 100% of the
usable rocket now Falcon is only
partially reusable the starship is going
to be a hundred percent reusable and
we've actually already started working
with NASA on using starship to send
astronauts to the surface of the Moon
for the first time since 1972
not only that starship will be refuel a
ball on orbit and the combination of
those two things will let us send people
basically anywhere in the solar system
with more payload for less money and I
think people have really been
contemplating it I think for the first
time we can seriously talk about things
like lunar bases or what SpaceX cares
about most a self-sustaining
civilization on Mars right so what
you're saying is I will have an
opportunity soon to get onboard one of
those space
so speaking of reusability and landing I
know you mentioned starship will be
refuel in orbit but Falcon does come
back and land back on earth what what
are the challenges with landing actually
landing on the moon and landing on a
planet like Mars yeah well you you can't
land like a plane because the Moon and
Mars either have no atmosphere or have a
very thin atmosphere and even if you
could there's no runway that someone's
built for you so that's one of the
reasons that we do propulsive landing on
Falcon because we want to figure out how
to do propulsive landing about
fundamental architecture works on
basically any planet if you have no
atmosphere like the moon you do a
propulsive landing burn all the way if
you have a thick atmosphere like Earth
you let the atmosphere slow you down as
you float down and do a short landing
boat at the end and for Mars which has
an atmosphere but a very thin one you do
something in between the two Wow
yeah that sounds really difficult and
I'm sure there's been a lot of effort
put into that can you tell us anything
about what we're working on now to get
us to a point where we can do a landing
like that in such a harsh environment
yeah so figuring out propulsive landing
is really the key part of it but what
people may not realize is that every
time we bring Falcon back we do
something called an entry burn so just
before we hit the atmosphere we like the
engines to slow the rocket down that
happens high up where the air is very
thin and it just so happens that the
conditions there are very similar to
what a Mars landing permit would look
like so even though it takes months to
get to Mars and you can only do it every
two years when the planets line up we
effectively get to practice Mars
propulsive landing every time we bring
Falcon back including hopefully today
Wow and as you mentioned every time you
bring Falcon back we learned something
new can you tell us a little bit more
about what we learn after the the
vehicles returned and we're able to
check out the vehicle
yes so Jessica actually mentioned this
earlier that you know I talked about how
cost is really one benefit of
reusability that reliability is the
other benefit
I mean imagine that you do all this
planning to send a rocket up through the
rigors of launch and reentry
but you don't get to see the rocket
afterwards and what we would like to do
with the reusability what we've been
able to do with Falcon 9 is see the
rocket inspect it and because of that
we've been able to correlate our models
pre-flight so what actually happens when
you launch re-enter and land a rocket
right instead of just guessing what
happened to the vehicle after it's left
that that is amazing well thank you
again for joining us today for a second
round of flu the weather works with us
today in a couple hours actually let's
throw it back to KSC with marine all
right actually we have Lauren here now
today's mission opens up the door to one
day allowing the general public to be
able to visit places like the Moon and
Mars and as you've heard through several
interviews today reusability is a really
really important part of that imagine if
every time you flew a plane from LA to
New York you threw it away at the end of
the flight that would means essentially
airline travel would be too expensive
costing hundreds and millions of dollars
a flight and almost no one would be able
to fly and so that's what SpaceX is
trying to do here with reuse allowing
not just a handful of people to be able
to go to space but tens of thousands and
hundreds of thousands of regular folks
like you and me to be able to to go to
space so you know myself you know when
people like me have a chance to go I
know my dream is to land on Jupiter's
moon Europa
scientists believe that there is a
liquid water ocean underneath the ice
and that it has the potential to be
habitable and so I'm super excited to
get up close and personal to maybe some
space fish meal and what about you where
would you go wow that's a pretty
interesting destination I think I would
like to go to Mars we've we've studied
Mars so much and looked at it and I
think maybe having a Martian base that
is dog friendly you know bring the pups
along because I think as we explore we
want to take our families our culture's
our traditions you know
with us and and you know flying with
Doug and Bob is cool but you know having
more people yeah the puffers taking the
coppers to space I mean you know they
already just needed some maybe some like
SpaceX type suits for them but it's it's
that's what it's all about exploration
like the settler is going the West you
know they took everything with them and
they started these new communities in
these new new traditions and I think
that's what we do with space travel we
start new traditions and communities and
bring everyone together as one one
family one civilization absolutely we're
here for it and knowing that the
opportunity to fly to space is a private
citizen is really just right around the
corner we have a new poll question on
Twitter for you if given the opportunity
to fly to the moon now we're talking the
moon would you fly to the South Pole
where no one has ever been or would you
go to the Apollo 11 landing site so
those are going to be some interesting
answers and while there is not a ton of
cargo on today's mission dragon is
carrying two very special payloads
aside from Bob and Doug of course the
first of those payloads is a series of
custom art pieces entitled humankind by
Los Angeles artist Christian Tristan
Eden's these indestructible double-sided
paintings made from gold brass and
aluminum celebrate how far humanity has
come as well as how far we still have to
go it includes a beautiful homage to the
Saturn 5 rocket as well as a nod to Bob
and Doug's current ride to space and you
can find more images and information
about these pieces on SpaceX's social
channels next in the spirit of inspiring
the next generation of explorers we
wanted to celebrate the class of 2020
from kindergarten all the way to
graduate school so SpaceX and NASA
invited students from around the world
to submit their photo to fly on
America's first human spaceflight in
nearly a decade
each graduates photo was used to create
a mosaic image of our beautiful planet
Earth which we printed and it's now
being flown aboard Bob and Doug's flight
on the crew Dragon spacecraft we
received nearly 100,000 photo
that's a ton so thank you and
congratulations graduates yeah I've got
a couple family members and friends who
submitted their photos I'm excited about
in their faces go to space in that
beautiful mosaic that was really cool
and again that's what it's all about you
know everyone coming together with their
experiences and bringing them forward to
to space and I you know I think regular
people fly into space I mean we're
SpaceX is going to be flying you know
non government people non military
people with people that have a desire to
explore and do new things and traditions
off planet as we say sometimes yeah I
mean all this time since we've had the
International Space Station it's been
government astronauts performing the
research because you're the only ones
we've been able to send right but some
tourists though we've had people that
paid their way on a Soyuz rocket sure
sure but it's really the billionaire
boys club you know that's what Pharrell
talks about with you know it cost so
much when the other space that I think
that price point will come down as we
make this more you know more amenable
for everyday people absolutely and
eventually being able to fly artists and
musicians and poets people can tell the
story of what they've seen out there in
a way that really connects to the soul
of people down on earth so they feel
inspired to go now following today's
mission we will be one step closer to a
future where we can all have that
opportunity to gain the orbital
perspective and explore new worlds in
just over an hour from now Bob and Doug
will be the first people to launch on an
American vehicle in almost a decade and
for the SpaceX team if I can try to
speak for all of us which is impossible
but I will say it has been an absolute
honor to have the opportunity today to
have this stage to show the world what
we've poured our hearts into over the
years with our partners at NASA and it's
just deeply humbling to know that the
agency and that Bob and Doug have
entrusted us with this critical mission
the the responsibility that's on our
shoulders is is huge and we're just so
grateful to be here today absolutely and
I know that you know our NASA teams
really share in that sentiment we heard
we heard from just a handful of them
earlier when Bob and Doug were riding
out to the
pat but there are just there's so many
people that were you know we're probably
never going to see or hear from on the
public stage but that have poured their
hearts and souls as you said into this
mission you know all the engineers up
late hours checking double check
checking triple checking everything to
troubleshoot and solve problems and get
us to this point so it's it's just
really awesome that we've made it to
this point when you think about legacy
Katherine Johnson who helped get John
Glenn to space her daughter's are
watching right now and that again that
legacy going forward to the future of
space travel yeah it's powerful Wow and
we heard from two icons of science and
exploration on Wednesday and we couldn't
resist sharing these shoutouts with you
one more time Wow we're making history
again the NASA program I am there with
you guys in spirit
Bob good luck I know you'll be fine
I'll be watching and they got everything
crossed arms legs
I'm tighten or not can't wait for you to
get back safely
[Music]
this is the first time a u.s. built
rocket has taken people into space in
nine years is quite an accomplishment so
for us at the Planetary Society more
rockets means more exploration more
people in space means more exploration
more countries involved in the endeavor
of space flight means more exploration
this is how we know the cosmos and our
place within it
so congratulations SpaceX here's wishing
your team and the crew especially a safe
journey and the joy of discovery let's
go so great to hear from William Shatner
and Bill Nye two very recognizable faces
following along on the mission and and
we want to go over to Dan and Jesse in
Hawthorne where we are now just one hour
and 18 minutes from launch dan Jesse hey
thanks Marie yeah one hour 18 minutes I
think we're tying ourselves and knots
just like Captain Kirk where we're
really hoping the weather cooperates in
about 20 minutes or so we might clear so
we're getting hopeful we're getting our
hopes up yes yes very excited again
we're t-minus one hour and 18 minutes
from launch and we are the anticipation
is real over here since arriving at the
spacecraft Bob and Doug were helped by
our closeout engineers to get into their
seats attach their suits to special
umbilicals that provide breathing air
pressurized nitrox and a communications
link to Dragon systems they conducted
leak checks which were successful and
communications checks with the core here
in Hawthorne which is the person who
will speak to them directly throughout
the mission as well as the launch
director in Florida this is where they
are checking their comm path through
both ground stations and the tracking
and data relay satellites that we'll use
to talk to the crew the entire way to
the station and after all of those suit
leak checks were successful the closeout
team was able to get out of the Dragon
capsule and seal up that hatch which
also got its own leak check and was
confirmed successful at this point the
closeout team is out of the path or away
from the BDA the blast danger area and
weather operators are about to kick off
their final checks on wind speeds at the
pad we're going to
during the final go/no-go for launch so
we're all keeping eyes on the weather
right now before we get to that final go
no-go all the various teams both NASA
and SpaceX are gonna do internal go
polls just making sure conditions are
right with Falcon 9 the dragon the crew
the range and the space station before
the final go is given so let's check
back in with the man over in Houston
Gary for a status and the team
supporting the space station for their
readiness for launch thanks Dan the team
here in Mission Control Houston remains
go for launch we're also very hopeful
about that weather all systems onboard
the station that are required to be
healthy for this mission are continuing
to look good Chris Cassidy is we're
wrapping up his workday and we'll be
watching Bob and Doug launch here in
just under an hour
so station power and communication
systems are normal computers and
networks used for monitoring dragons
approach have been checked out and the
cabins and the station cabins atmosphere
and pressure are as expected and ready
to welcome two new crew members aboard
Mission Control will be closely
monitoring Bob and Doug's flight and
checking off milestones for most of the
flight and this very same team will be
coming back tomorrow to be ready when
dragon gets in range of the
international space station and we begin
integrated operations and prepare for
Dragon stocking so I'll send it back
International Space Station team here is
ready for launch
go Falcon 9 go dragon and Godspeed to
Bob and Doug
all right thanks Gary if you are just
now joining us you picked a really good
time we're just a little over an hour to
launch and welcome to our coverage for
the mission known as demonstration
mission two or demo two liftoff time
still holding for 322 p.m. Eastern
tracking no issues with Falcon 9 or
dragon everything good with the range so
far we're just really keeping an eye on
that weather over the last three hours
our crew members Doug Hurley and Bob
bankin Don their SpaceX suits in the
historic crew quarters suit up room
after that they walked out of crew
quarters just as every astronaut to fly
from space from this port has done since
Apollo 7 and then they were transported
over to the pad where the crew members
entered the SpaceX crew Dragon
spacecraft that we're looking in live
today is a historic lunch it will be the
first time a commercially built
spacecraft will launch people into orbit
and the first time the US has sent
people to the space station from
American soil since 2011 with the
retirement of the space shuttle program
over the next hour we will conduct a
series of polls to get ready for launch
have Bob and Doug arm the launch escape
system and begin fueling Falcon 9 launch
is set for 322 p.m. Eastern this will
include a 12 minute flight to orbit and
then a 19-hour flight to dock with the
International Space Station tomorrow
morning today's mission is the
culmination of years of work between
teams at SpaceX and NASA demo2 is gonna
be an end-to-end flight test starting
with this launch today going on to dock
with the space station tomorrow and then
splashing down at the end of their
mission this is going to be the final
test for NASA to certify SpaceX for
regular crew flights to the space
station we've been hearing a little bit
from the crew onboard dragon which you
can see on your right screen they are
currently strapped into their seats and
already through communications and leak
checks they're able to follow all the
milestones still ahead on those display
panels just above them getting insight
into all Dragon and Falcon 9 systems as
we proceed towards launch so at t-minus
one hour in 13 minutes let's check in
with
I for a status update on the vehicles
what's the update John thank Jessie well
not much it not much to add to what Dan
and Jessie just brought up we had a
smooth countdown this afternoon SpaceX
team is working no issues as the pace
begins to pick up here in the last 70
minutes on Falcon 9 we did get the team
on console earlier you heard the complex
between the responsible engineers and
the crew the engineers will be making
calls on asset for the crews benefit so
they want to make sure that they could
hear before we go the propulsion
checkouts of the first and second stages
are beginning right now we're watching
them begin to go through the process
opening valves that check will go for
about another 10 minutes and that'll be
our last one until propellant loading
now the team will assess readiness for
launch with a final go no-go poll at
t-minus 45 minutes and that will be
followed by propellant loading starting
at t-minus 35 minutes now earlier today
dragon operators also performed a series
of checkouts of dragons flight systems
the spacecraft is also currently go for
launch our nasa Crew astronauts Doug
Hurley and Bob Behnken are currently
inside dragon the hatch is closed
the SpaceX ground crew has left the
tower the next major event for Dragon is
retracted the crew access arm that you
can see currently alongside the capsule
that will happen somewhere between
t-minus 45 and t-minus 42 minutes now
the range is currently clear for launch
from historic pad 39a the worldwide
network of ground stations and the
tracking and data relay satellites are
ready to support dragon as it heads into
orbit the weather that's the one concern
we will get a weather brief at t-minus
one hour so just under 12 minutes from
now currently the ground and upper
altitude winds are go so that's one
thing that we can check is Green at the
current time we did have some rain
earlier that appears to have led up but
we are red on conditions for both the
electric field at surface levels
lightning and cumulus clouds there is a
expectation at a forecast that will be
coming up at about t-minus one hour also
may give us clearance of those
conditions so everything is focusing now
on the weather brief at t-minus 1 hours
also we should hope to hear about the
final check on the asset corridor that's
the weather along the Atlantic seaboard
in case dragon had to abort on the way
to space the conditions there have been
marginal but the expectation that it
would be good for launch but we will get
all of that coming up here very shortly
prior to entering propellant load now
today we are aiming for a launch at 3:20
2:45 p.m. Eastern Daylight Saving Time
or 19 hours 22 minutes 45 seconds
Universal Time once we begin loading
propellant
there's no opportunity to change t0 so
once propel is loading we're committed
and we'll get one chance at it today but
currently at t-minus one hour ten
minutes and thirty seconds everything
except the weather is go for launch
thanks John for that detailed update
we've got an extensive history now of
flying Falcon 9 from the Florida coast
and just last year completed a test run
of the mission worth less than an hour
from beginning here today the purpose of
that mission was to demonstrate dragons
capability to safely and reliably fly to
and from the International Space Station
the success of demo1 was a really
exciting moment to where we are today
and right now we're getting ready to fly
US astronauts from unisol for the first
time since 2011 dragon and Falcon 9
together have years of operational
experience or what we refer to as flight
heritage as I mentioned earlier spacex
has successfully completed 21 flights
with dragon to and from orbit since 2010
including 20 trips to the international
space station not only have we conducted
thousands of hours of testing we've also
enhanced and added a number of safety
features to Dragon much of what was
learned with the cargo dragon was
leveraged in the design
this new vehicle it's fully autonomous
which means it can basically fly itself
but also features that full manual
override capability just in case of
emergency many of the other enhancements
helped towards SpaceX's goal of
reusability and less refurbishment time
between missions so let's take a closer
look at these advancements standing at
almost 27 feet tall from the very bottom
of the trunk to the very top of the
nosecone crew dragons comprised of two
main elements you have the capsule which
is designed to hold crew and pressurize
cargo and then you have the trunk which
holds unpressurized cargo as well as
having a solar array and radiator and
the nosecone at the top of the capsule
protects the docking system as well as
the get guidance navigation control
system or what we call GNC the nose cone
opens for docking and remains attached
to the crew Dragon spacecraft and that's
unlike the previous version of Dragon
and that helps towards our reusability
efforts
lelee ops at the nose cone is that trunk
it has attachment points for Falcon 9
the Dragon capsule and it can hold cargo
on the very outside of the trunk one
half of it of it contains a radiator
that rejects heat from the active
thermal control system into space that's
the white part and that uses SpaceX's
new pekin silane technology the other
half contains the solar cells used to
charge the spacecraft batteries and
though we only have two astronauts on
board today the spacecraft is actually
designed to accommodate up to seven crew
members with modular seats that can be
removed and replaced by additional cargo
the seats are made of carbon fiber and
our custom size for any crew member
flying onboard the control panel
centered right between the pilot and the
commander seats and has those three
touchscreen displays that gives the crew
insight into dragon and even the ability
to operate the vehicle and fly it
manually and finally our super Draco
launch escape system is a key safety
feature of crew dragon giving the crew
the ability to safely escape from the
time of launch all the way to orbit as
we look to the future beyond this test
flight later this year the first
operational crewed mission for NASA will
take place NASA astronauts Mike Hawk
doesn't
my to review your launch commit criteria
and indicate readiness at the
appropriate time step 54 69 for load and
launch that's a good sign that was the
launch director we're getting ready to
pull the team's as we move towards that
go no-go for propellant loading which
happens at about 45 minutes before
launch but back to our crew one mission
NASA astronauts Mike Hopkins Victor
Glover and Shanna Walker and sweetie
Noguchi of the japan aerospace
exploration agency or JAXA were chosen
to support this mission but today Doug
Hurley is the spacecraft commander for
this mission
he previously flew on to space shuttle
missions as the pilot on sts-127 and STS
135 which was the final space shuttle
flight here's a closer look at Doug
Hurley very excited yeah
very excitable oh yeah I think we're
ready I think we're certainly ready
joining the SpaceX demo to test he is a
marine corps colonel and test pilot he
was selected as an astronaut in 2000 he
piloted space shuttle endeavour and
Atlantis for sts-135 the final space
shuttle mission introducing NASA
astronauts Doug Hurley
[Applause]
it's a life-changing process in so many
ways to fly it into space it's just
overwhelming in some some respects just
the sensations the rumbling the shaking
the acceleration my name is Doug Hurley
and I'm the spacecraft commander for the
demo2 mission to the International Space
Station this will be the first time the
dragon that crew on board and so there's
a myriad of objectives we want to
achieve for this mission what would work
on orbit what might not work on orbit
what would definitely work to be able to
just have the entire integrated team
that's gonna support us getting to and
from space station it was really neat
being part of it you know we are the
lucky ones that get to fly it
but we certainly not for one second take
for granted the amount of effort that so
many other people had to put into this
to make it successful for Chuck
personally he's worked so hard through
his entire life to get to where we are
right now as a test pilot this would be
the dream to fly any vehicle so it makes
me so happy to see that he gets to be
part of this mission the spacecraft
commander I'm just glad to see his hard
work and his dreams come true for that
it's been a long road in a lot of ways
for not only us but certainly for all
the folks that work in the Commercial
Crew program as well as SpaceX in our
case just working to get to this point
[Music]
and we're a little over one hour three
and a half minutes away from launch now
let's learn a little bit more about the
man sitting next to Doug Hurley inside
dragon that's a astronaut Bob bankin my
career at NASA is a kind of spanned a
couple of decades at this point I
arrived with the class of 2000 went
through the training program primarily
focused on the space shuttle and the
International Space Station learning
those systems having launched a couple
times on vehicles you know the the
second time was definitely different
than the first time you can feel a
little bit guilty hey should I study one
more thing or one more piece of
information I should get am I really
prepared or not so that's definitely
different between where I was on my
first flight and where I'm at right now
for me personally as a spouse watching
everything that bob has put into this
over the last five years the dedication
that he's shown the perseverance is
pretty special for both of us though the
way our minds work it won't be until
sort of the mission is complete that you
have really a chance to savor it and
celebrate it this is a huge
accomplishment for an Air Force flight
test engineer to be part of the
demonstration mission of a brand new
vehicle it's going to be amazing
without a partner that has that same
appreciation I think it can be
challenging for some folks there's a
there's a lot of work and a lot of time
that takes away from family that you
know that my spouse appreciates and I
love her for that on a deeply personal
level I'm really excited that my son is
get to get a chance to see me I launch
into space being an astronaut has been a
little bit of an abstraction thing for
him because he's seen me do it in old
videos but he hasn't seen me do it for
real and so I'm excited for him to see
how this launch really my role on the
demo2 mission is to make sure that we
get this vehicle tested and evaluated so
that we can move on to more operational
missions at the International Space
Station
we've got a lot of objectives onboard
the vehicle that we need to accomplish
to really make sure that it's good to go
well make sure all those systems are
working during the test flight so that
the future missions will have them
available even if they don't plan to
utilize them through years of the the
NASA team I'm helping to share that
experience and teaching them the lessons
that we've learned by going through this
now there's another capability in the
u.s. besides NASA to operate something
of this magnitude I want to thank the
entire Commercial Crew program team
that's worked together to get to this
point where we've got vehicles in the
launch pad ready to head to the
International Space Station if we look
even further into the not so distant
future flying on a mission to space will
be an option for more people as SpaceX
plans to also fly private astronauts
onboard dragon earlier this year SpaceX
signed an agreement with these space
tourism companies space adventures to
fly up to four passengers on an orbital
trip aboard dragon as early as next year
and of course it's NASA that is making
private astronaut missions to the space
station of possibility we are looking
forward to these missions and we hope
that you guys are all - all right we are
just 20 seconds away from t-minus one
hour this is going to be a really big
moment that everyone's gonna want to
listen to we're expecting a weather
update obviously hoping that the weather
is improving and so we should find out
in the next 10 seconds or so so we're
gonna stand by for a moment and wait for
the Corps to give Bob and Doug a call
and then we'll all hear it SpaceX we're
at t-minus one hour you are go for
Section six when ready report go for
lunch we'll put it work
and that right there was a call for the
crew to refer to some of their
procedures they do some final checks you
can see them checking harnesses checking
helmets just making sure that they're
strapped in and ready to go and once
they're done with that the crew will
report their readiness for launch
they sex dragon in six decimal four by
manera go for launch
copy go for launch and next up will be
gonna go for t-minus 45
all right the crew is go for launch so
we are inside of one hour still waiting
for the weather update but I mean this
day this day is one for the history
books we're returning crewed launches to
station from American soil on American
Rockets it's been almost nine long years
since we retired the space shuttle
program I remember that day I'm gonna
remember this day it's been a long road
to get here countless hours by thousands
of dedicated professionals from NASA and
SpaceX it's been an exciting week but
this last final hour is just so exciting
right now
today's mission will be crew Dragons
second test flight and its first test
with humans on board it's been an
awesome countdown so far whether we're
still waiting for that update so it's
still a watch item but the crew is go
for launch so at t-minus 45 minutes
hopefully we'll get an update on that
weather we've had a really clean
countdown so far it started with suit up
just over three hours ago the SpaceX
team helping Bob and Doug put on their
suits conducting initial checkouts
including an initial pressure and leak
check before they got to the actual
walkout and all of that done and that
operations and check-out facility the
crew walkout was where Bob and Doug gave
their final goodbyes to friends and
family gathered outside the operations
and check-out building before they began
at roughly 20 minute ride to pad 39a
touching moment saying goodbye to their
family both their wives and sons right
in front of them very touching moment
incredible to be able to watch these
moments and as they got into their
Tesla's we got to watch them ride all
the way to the pad and we got some great
footage there and as you can see on your
screen this is some playback from
earlier of them getting into those
Tesla's about to make that drive down to
the pad once they got to the pad they
did take a minute to take in the sights
and they headed up the fixed service
structure to begin the process called
true angrist where Bob and Doug entered
the and there you can see on your screen
as they're coming through the crew
access arm entering the white room right
before they are able to ingress into the
vehicle there again this is from earlier
this off earlier and as we said that
white room the last place on planet
Earth they're standing before they climb
into dragon for the ride uphill SpaceX
carrying over a tradition that NASA had
had where that was traditionally the
room from Gemini Apollo and the space
shuttle that last place about 30 minutes
ago we're back with some live video here
the team was able to close dragon's
hatch with Bob and Doug's safe inside so
we are under an hour ago things are
gonna pick up as we get close to that go
no-go to begin propellant loading and
then arming the launch escape system the
crew pull for readiness was completed at
t-minus 60 minutes and the dragon pull
for prop load is coming up here in just
about 30 seconds at t minus 55 minutes
and then following that will be t-minus
45 minutes will be the internal Mission
Control Hawthorne Pole and then they
launch director's pull for propellant
loading when we get to about t-minus 40
minutes the crew access arm will retract
and Bob and Doug will get the call to
close their visors
and armed the launch escape system this
is the automated system in place that
can fire the eight super Draco thrusters
on dragon to quickly separate the crew
from the rocket either on the pad or
during the flight on the ride up hill
and once we reach t-minus 35 minutes
propellant loading for the Falcon 9 will
begin we got there on Wednesday we got
all the way down to about 17 minutes
before launch before we had to cancel
because of weather but we're still
optimistic right now conditions have
been improving and so we're looking to
press ahead once again into loading fuel
onto that Falcon 9 rocket throughout the
countdown we've been getting some
incredible views of the astronauts
inside dragon just making all of their
final preparations close-up views of
their suits and on the displays as they
just are strapped in and ready for
launch
the team's often describe the suits as
an extension of that Dragon spacecraft
you can always think of it as a mini
spacecraft inside of a spacecraft all of
the life-support everything that they
need just like the cavity and Benoit
technical pole is complete no
constraints to proceed into launch
escape system arming and propellant load
and there's that call out that the crew
is ready they are ready to load prop
onto dragon so we are pushing forward
towards t0 and while those suits do look
great they are also engineered to
correct or connect directly into dragon
seats to provide communications cooling
and the ability to pressurize it's
necessary all right well we did get the
call out that the technical teams in the
ground are ready for launch escape
arming and propellant loading again
things starting to pick up things really
starting to feel real let's jump down
real quick to the team at Kennedy see if
you guys are just as excited I can't sit
still right now yeah it's it's hard to
sit still in here right lane still I
know I know it's it's so awesome when we
see them sitting there in their suits
were less than an hour away now
so far things look like we might make it
we might make it um so I want to ask you
what it was like the first time you put
on a spacesuit when you knew you were
going to space oh that was February of
2008 we were in the ONC building getting
the pumpkin suits on a little bit
different than the SpaceX fly SpaceX is
but it was it was kind of surreal you
know and to think that all these it took
10 years of training to fly in space it
took me 10 years from when I got in the
Corps 1998 to fly in February 2008 so it
was a long road to get there but it was
so worth it and so sweet and you know
learning how to use the green apple the
connections for oxygen for cooling much
different than these suits that we have
here with SpaceX and so it's a lot more
complicated to to go through that whole
series of things that you have to do to
make sure you're safe in the suit but
we've evolved we're ready and they look
so cool and calm and collected in their
their suits and then the vehicle they're
focusing and getting ready to find space
and there's so much excitement around
the center I know Leland you've been
getting some messages you got another
message from another astronaut yeah
sunny Williams okay so sunny Qadri she
was one of the original four who trained
with Bob and Doug from the beginning of
the Commercial Crew program and she's
one of my classmates look at her there
what is she wearing today I'm asking
where the warm ball yeah yeah she can
mix it up but yeah Sunny's awesome she's
training to fly on the Boeing Starliner
on in the not-too-distant future so
really glad she's watching and showing
some love so thanks a lot Sonny for
sending that note and again we're
looking at a live view of the crew
dragon on top of a falcon 9 rocket you
can see the crew access arm to the right
of your screen that's the hallway that
Bob and Doug walked down to get into the
white room which was the last place we
saw them standing up before they climbed
inside dragon and again that wider shot
their launch complex 39a where we are
inside of an hour
from liftoff and I think we're just a
couple minutes away from the pole we're
gonna hear before they start propellant
load again a two-stage rocket there and
gosh you guys the weather looks it looks
not that bad I mean obviously that is
not an official forecast but it doesn't
look quite as bad as it did Wednesday
we've got a little bit better odds so
there's the countdown clock where we're
gonna pause to listen to that calm
if you're just joining us we're less
than 50 minutes from the scheduled
liftoff of the Falcon 9 rocket carrying
crew dragon and if we start to hear any
kind of update on weather or pulling we
will pause to listen in for that but if
things go as scheduled we should be
hearing the launch director verified go
for propellant load at about t minus t
minus 45 minutes so we're gonna send it
over to Hawthorne to carry the ball John
instructor or Jesse are you there that's
whether it's go at this time
dragon Cathy got weather and there you
heard that call out so far we have good
weather we are go for launch today this
is getting really exciting I don't know
about you Dan
I heard it's beating pretty fast right
now waiting for those words since
Wednesday oh yeah we did we did hear a
call to the crew just in case you missed
it that they were only tracking one
final weather constraint it was the
cumulus cloud rule they were expecting
it to clear up within 10 minutes and
it's cleared up now so we are currently
go on weather yes and it's been pretty
incredible to be so close to launch and
the road leading up to this point has
been pretty incredible as well it has
been it's been a partnership between
NASA and SpaceX we've been working
together since we since SpaceX started
flying cargo to the International Space
Station now getting ready to launch crew
and we've been really fortunate to work
with not only a lot of international
partners on the international space
station but a lot every writer here the
control room will be closing doors here
once we start with propellant load any
last-minute bio breaks please go ahead
compost over the next few minutes and
the launch launch director just getting
the teams ready we'll be coming up on
that propellant loading again that
starts at about 35 minutes prior to
liftoff so in about 12 minutes from now
there's gonna be a go no-go coming up
really soon so let's go over to our man
John I for the latest John
Steve - 47 minutes 24 seconds we're
continuing countdown as you just heard
the launch director and launch team are
preparing for the readiness for launch
Paul now the launch director is
currently checking with dragon mission
director NASA launch manager for their
readiness and actually it sounds like
everybody is good there the launch
director will then ask the team he'll
tell them the pole is open and the 13
members of the SpaceX launch team will
be electrically pulled for their go to
load propellant as well as continue all
the way to launch now we will hear that
poll results and a briefing from the
launch director at about t-minus 45
minutes the good news right now is that
the weather is go all the conditions
that were read shortly a while ago at
t-minus one hour have cleared where is
the weather forecaster said cautiously
optomistic cut down the from those
complete we're go for propellant load
well we got an early call out this ultra
chokes here to retract the access
Armenta however that our meeting access
arm retract at t-minus 45 minutes got an
early call from SpaceX launch director
Mike Taylor that the pole is go you also
heard the direction t-minus 45 minutes
to prepare for retrack of the crew arm
as we hear more discussion we'll stop
and let you listen in but right now
weather for liftoff ground level winds
are good 10 to 15 miles an hour well
within limit upper altitude balloons
show that conditions are acceptable the
red weather conditions have cleared up
the last one being cumulus clouds and
the probability of violation is set at
30 percent right now so that's 70
percent chance of good weather we're
continuing to watch there is about a
less than 10 percent chance of lightning
we're also watching the abort corridor
off of the Atlantic coast in case for
example at stage separation dragon had
to abort into the ocean the conditions
there are acceptable there has not been
light
lately the weather winds are good
light rain it is go but NASA is going to
continue to watch those conditions
t-minus 45 minutes and Counting reminder
on hold and launch escape protocol for
non urgent no-go conditions recency II
or LD they will approve a boarding
launch out of sequence and proceed to
launch abort for urgent issues affecting
the safety of the operation operator
shall call hold hold hold on the
countdown net launch control immediately
abort the launch on a sequence and
proceed to the launch abort auto
sequence operators also advise launch
director weather structural breaker
prior is imminent occurring
her dragon manual escape flight rules a
reminder on fire alarm instructions any
event of a fire alarm key operators
previously briefed will remain at their
post fall that alarm is evaluated the
event that personal safety is threatened
evacuate to the south facing emergency
exit which leads directly outside at
this time weather is go for launch you
can see on the screen we're inside
t-minus 40 we're t-minus 40 four minutes
five seconds crew access for a SpaceX
launch director is given the final brief
to the crew and we will beginning a
little propellant loading at t-minus 35
minutes so right now on Falcon 9 ready
to get into propellant loading dragon
crew getting configured set up the arm
is pulling away the range is go for
launch they continue to monitor the air
and the sea space everything looks good
and we finally have gotten green across
the board on the weather conditions but
we can't take a deep breath quite yet
we're gonna have to watch the weather
all the way down to t0
both here at Kennedy Space Center and
out in the Atlantic in the abort zones
now earlier we saw many of you following
the launch from the United States on our
hotspot map now that we're inside now
where we're seeing large numbers of
folks logging on tuning in from coast to
coast and around the world so we'd like
to know is this your first time watching
a launch live not counting Wednesday and
if not how many
have you seen before tell us using the
hashtag watch America from your favorite
social media platform and with that at
t-minus 42 minutes 50 seconds conditions
are go and we are counting down for an
on-time launch let's send it back
Kennedy Space Center as the action
begins to pick up on the fed dragon
SpaceX you're go for Section seven
clothes visors and arm launch escape
system we will but section seven and
we're crisis coming closer all right the
countdown clock is continuing to take my
heart is continuing to beat five million
beats a second and we are getting so so
close right dragon and seven point two
visors are close we're arming launch
escape system has just heard the crew is
arming the launch escape system that is
one of the absolute last big milestones
prior to liftoff other than nominal
Falcon operations so just a minute ago
we saw the crew access arm retract and
obviously we just heard on the comms Bob
and Doug getting ready to arm the launch
escape system and so that is something
that protects them all the way to orbit
so when when fueling starts at about
t-minus 35 minutes so just over six
minutes from now they will have the
capability to abort to separate from
Falcon 9 either on the pad or even after
liftoff that's a critical safety
capability and we are going to go over
to Hawthorne now to take us through
these next minutes Jesse or section
pushing we did hear that call out that
they are arming the launch escape
systems are very exciting SpaceX has
designed a crew dragon and Falcon 9 to
be the safest launches launch system
ever flown so we brought back NIC Picone
SpaceX has nicked the cone
more about this again thanks for coming
back and joining us today Nick hey Jesse
happy to be here this is the monitoring
launch here with our recovery and ground
operations tips awesome and Nicky was
our mission manager for our inflatable
tests earlier this year and now works on
the StarLink team Nick on Wednesday you
talked about the launch escape system
could you just give us a brief summary
today for those that are joining today
sure so the launch escape system again
is our ultimate safety feature to keep
Bob and Doug safe in the event of a
major falcon anomaly on the pad the
system is designed to automatically fire
if either vehicle detects a dangerous
condition developing if that happens
dragon will use its eight super Draco
engines to push the capsule off and away
to a safe distance away from this Falcon
miss this capability is absolutely
critical
it's what keeps the crew safe and we're
now acting on the pad with it protecting
the crew and as you mentioned the launch
escape system allows the dragon to
separate and get away from the vehicle I
believe it goes into the ocean what what
happens after it lands safely in the
ocean correct so for most of our failure
modes the
you
if something happens so the nominal
stuff is all kind of automated but if
something happens where they have to
intervene with those touchscreens that's
what they're thinking and we are we're
just inside 23 minutes now so on
Wednesday we were five minutes further
in the countdown when we heard that call
to scrub and we the weather was still
very touch-and-go at this point on
Wednesday but today it at least for
right now I don't want to jinx better
today yeah and it feels like I'm feeling
it a lot more than and you know speaking
of Bob and Doug and them being really
calm and cool and collected hasn't had
the opportunity to be in meetings with
them and to watch them train I have to
say and to all of my friends who work
with them every single day
the feedback is always just what great
people they are right and just how not
just bright and sharp they are but just
good people and around the office we
often refer to them as the dads
the dad's they're dad's they are dead
and we've met their families and when
you sweetie you see people in that very
personal level it starts to mean so much
there they are a part of our team you
know they're and they're not a customer
they're our team they're not a payload
they're our team they're our family and
so we're just so excited to see the dads
up there today all right we're gonna go
send it over to Gary for an update from
Houston Gary hey Murray the Space
Station team here is focused all eyes
are on the system checks that are
happening across the board and we're
listening in as we close in on launch
and I can tell you that things are
looking very good
Chris KSD will be watching from the
International Space Station right now
flying over the Pacific Ocean it's
heading to cross right over the launch
pad we might even get some good views
from the station hope to be capturing
those we'll have the launch view in the
big screen up front and everyone's
excited to see our two crew members on
their way to the International Space
Station but before we get to it I just
want to pass on good luck from the
entire flight operations community here
in Houston it's always exciting to be
doing something wholly new and
history-making with stage
operations and we can't wait to see our
team members Bob and Doug in low Earth
orbit and heading to the International
Space Station that's it from us here in
Mission Control Houston
I'll send it back over to the team in
Hawthorne for the latest happening there
John t-minus 20 minutes 30 seconds we
come down everything is still looking
good for launch of Falcon 9 and Dragon
22 minutes 45 seconds after the hour
[Music]
you can see a large white cloud coming
off of the strong back that is normal as
we get ready to load the second stage
with liquid oxygen we have to chill in
the plumbing lines going up that strong
back and so as we relieve pressure the
moist humid Florida air condenses around
it and that gives you the cloud so that
tells us that things are actually on
schedule we did begin propellant load at
t-minus 35 minutes fuel loading on the
second stage I believe we just heard the
call out that it is complete first stage
feel load is continuing and right now
that's a little more than it's about 60%
of the way full so things are looking
good
second stage is getting ready to begin
the liquid oxygen loading after they
finished chilling in the lines that you
see on the monitor they'll begin to load
at t-minus 16 minutes and 30 seconds the
range right now is go ready to support
weather continues to be go now as we
inch our way closer we're keeping our
fingers crossed we're waiting to hear if
anybody calls out an issue but for the
moment as you can see on the screen it
looks good now on the dragon car I'd the
dragon mission director and the team
there are reporting no issues they've
done their communications checkouts the
crew access arm as you can see is
retracted away from the spacecraft the
crew is strapped in and they are ready
to go now final instructions we'll be
going to the crew at t-minus 10 minutes
the crew displays will be configured for
launch and that setup will give
astronauts Bob Behnken and Doug Hurley
insight into how the launch is
proceeding and provides constant updates
on vehicle health we've already heard
the crew give their go
close their visors and get ready for
launch for Dragon it'll enter terminal
count at t-minus five minutes when it
transitions the internal power will hear
continued call-outs on the countdown net
as we get close to zero and to liftoff
but right now at t-minus 18 minutes 15
seconds everything continues to be go
for an on-time launch so Dan Jessie
things looking pretty good how are they
doing over at your stand
things are great from about 15 feet away
from you John I and honestly things are
looking pretty great down at the pad
there we're seeing a lot more blue in
the sky Green is the color we want when
we're talking about weather and that's
wherever sitting right now so we're
continuing to countdown we are under 18
minutes away from liftoff again it's an
instantaneous liftoff at it's gonna be
12 22 and 45 seconds here on the west
coast 322 and 45 seconds over on the
East Coast there in Florida just a
reminder it's going to be about a 90
minute ride up to orbit for the Falcon 9
and Bob and Doug on board dragon
it'll be a two-stage flight so we'll see
you the first age fly until we hear miko
or main engine cutoff about two and a
half minutes into flight after that the
second stage will take over and continue
to power them the rest of the way
second engine cutoff comes in just under
nine minutes at about 8 minutes and 44
seconds following that second stage
completing its job it'll continue to
coast for about 3 minutes they'll do a
slight attitude adjustment and no out
any rate so make sure it's not in any
kind of a spin before they do separation
so that's when the Dragon spacecraft
will physically separate from the Falcon
9 vehicle and Bob and Doug will be
flying free it's about a 19 hour ride if
we launch today on time so that means
Bob and Doug will get on orbit they'll
have a number of burns or those firings
of those Draco thrusters that they'll do
will be to lock load started we hear the
locks the liquid oxygen load has now
started on stage two again they're gonna
be doing a series of burns
the way uphill towards the International
Space Station v spread out over the the
first 16 hours or so of their flight
until they get much closer and it's time
for that approach docking and we are
expecting that with an on-time launch to
happen today that'll be coming tomorrow
in the afternoon all right now that
we're under 16 minutes away we have a
special guest joining us I'm gonna toss
it over to Jesse we are t-minus 15
minutes and 45 seconds from liftoff of
our second demonstration mission today
and we have the honor of having speed
ilan for hiring me we think you want for
hiring use well thank you so much for
joining us we'll let you get back to
Mission Control and good luck with
launch today thanks Jesse and Godspeed
Bob and Doug well we are so excited we
are just a few minutes away from
countdown so we are going to turn it
over to Dan and John for the final
minutes and terminal count I'll take it
away John G - 13 minutes 30 seconds
continuing to countdown we're continuing
to load Phil onto the first stage that
should finish up in just about 6 minutes
Phil is completely loaded on the second
stage that's closed out and we are
continuing to load liquid oxygen on both
the first and second stage the liquid
oxygen load beginning on the second
stage just about three and a half
minutes ago we are also loading courage
and a key Liam into these storage
vessels on the first and second stage
getting in the last little bits of
helium when we keep it cryogenic cold
and liquefied that gets us just like we
do with liquid oxygen the maximum amount
into the storage volume so that we can
get the most performance out of the
vehicle right now we are in a fairly
quiet state on the vehicle ground pump
continuing to put the propellant into
first and second stages next significant
issue call-outs that we're gonna hear
will probably be inside the t-minus 10
minutes when they talk to the crew we'll
listen for that but at the moment
everything continuing to look good at
t-minus 12 minutes and 20 seconds
getting real close now John it's only a
little over 12 minutes away
just a reminder for everybody it's about
a nine minute ride of he'll we'll have
some dueling boxes going on as that
first age is going to be coming home
while the second stage is carrying Bob
and Doug into orbit obviously we'll be
keeping an eye on our astronauts the
whole way uphill some of the calls that
you'll be hearing as there will be what
we call performance calls
over the dragon the ground the entire
way uphill and you'll just hear some of
the SpaceX Engineers calling out
trajectories and booster performance so
we're always looking for that word
nominal I know that's one of John's
favorite words that's one of mine too we
want to hear novel as much as possible
up on the way uphill you might also hear
some number and letter combinations and
those correspond to the different abort
zones that Bob and daughter in during
their flight uphill there's one A and
one B which signify that they're on the
first stage those carry them from there
in the Cape all the way up to about the
very top of North Carolina and then
we'll have 2a through 2e or two echo and
that will be on the second stage and
that goes from North Carolina all the
way up to about the tip of Newfoundland
so in the northern Atlantic and then
there is a zone of the northern Atlantic
that we're going to avoid and so you
should hear the call out be something
similar to forward to Shannon and that
just refers to Shannon Ireland which
they'll be going off the coast of
Ireland at the later stages of the
second stage if they have to abort
so just prepping you now for some of
those calls you're hopefully going to
hear that word nominal a whole lot on
the way uphill ten and a half minutes
things are pretty quiet as John I said
it'll pick up it right at about ten
minutes we'll wait for the crew just to
confirm that their displays are in order
the crew is already strapped in and
reported that they are go for launch and
we'll continue to watch the fuel gauges
tick up on the Falcon 9 vehicle until
fueling cuts off at just about two
minutes prior to launch
dragon SpaceX confirmed displays are
configure for lunch wait a second
displays are configured for launch
copy Bob Doug on behalf of the entire
SpaceX team it's been a huge honor to
help you get ready for today's historic
mission know that we're with you have an
amazing flight and enjoy those views of
our beautiful planet
thanks Jake it is absolutely our honor
to be part of this huge effort to get
the United States back in the launch
business we'll talk to you for more -
thank you thanks for those words
SpaceX Corps so again that voice that's
gonna be talking to Bob and Doug
throughout their mission
from right here in Hawthorne just
offering a few quick words the crew did
confirm their crew displays are
configured for launch we are coming up
on nine minutes and Counting we've
gotten through t-minus 10 minute with
the career discussions activity is now
gonna switch over to Falcon 9 our next
major event comes at t-minus seven
minutes we begin what we call engine
chill tree valves will open those
currently separate propellants on the
first stage from getting down to the
merlin engines will open the pre valves
that allow feel liquid oxygen to flow to
the top of the pumps and more
importantly when we open the valves that
allow us to begin chilling the nine
merlin 1d turbo pumps on the first stage
engine it'll take a few minutes to get
them cold enough to where they would
then be ready to pass the large amounts
of liquid oxygen through the pumps and
into the main thrust chambers when we
get to engine ignition at t-minus two
seconds we don't want to try to run a
highly chilled liquid oxygen through a
warm pump you would flash that into gas
and running gas to a high speed is not a
good thing so right now we are waiting
for t-minus seven minutes that'll start
the engine chill shortly after that we
will get the feel shut down
listening to the SpaceX launch director
in the background there as I mentioned
at t-minus seven minutes as we start to
chill we will also get into the final
topping off of stage one feel and then
the fuel load will complete
stage 1 and stage 2 engine chill has
started we've heard the call-out
Stage one engine chill has started
that's gone up to the crew so that
they've got situational awareness as I
mentioned the free vowels are open and
now we are topping off first stage feel
getting ready to finish the fuel load
liquid oxygen load on first and second
stage will continue until the last three
to two minutes of the countdown we
should hear that call out our p1 load
complete coming up in about six minutes
again our p1 is just that densified
kerosene or that rocket fuel that Falcon
9 is gonna be used to power Bob and Doug
to orbit today and stage 1 fuel is quote
that right on time that color indicates
that the feel loading on the first stage
is complete draining back the lines now
so first stage and second stage feel our
complete liquid oxygen loading is
continuing on both stages you can see on
the view on the left side of monitor the
condensation the cold gas wrapped around
the stages is the tank skins are chilled
by the densified liquid oxygen picking
up the humidity from our Florida or it
looks like at this moment we're a little
more than 90 percent full on the
oxidizer on the first age ticking up
towards that eighty percent mark on the
second stage we'll be counting down all
the way till about two or three minutes
as John I just said until everything is
low and I haters those note and then we
will be go for launch
dragon has transition to configure for
terminal count vehicle tanks pressing
for strong back the track
we're pressurizing the Falcon 9 tanks
we're going to open the clamp arm around
the second stage and begin to retract
the strong back we'll move back about
two degrees that'll get us to the
liftoff position ant lift off the strong
rack will then recline about 45 degrees
discarded stage to our viewing bleed
launch director called out the strong
back retract has started on the left
you'll see it go back just a couple of
degrees page one are currently just four
minutes away from liftoff I got at this
moment Bob and Doug are really just
laser focused on those displays they
have in sight directly into dragon in
the Falcon 9 they're able to see where
their fuel loading is that how
everything is progressing down with the
count they appear final setup started
three and a half minutes from launch and
the strong back is now reclining away
from the Falcon 9
I'm bagging lighter purges oh they'll
believe dragon has transitioned to
terminal count and his own internal pill
page one lock load close that
okay we're t-minus two minutes 42
seconds Stage one locks load is closed
out Stage two will continue to load for
about another half a minute or so once
we get the completion of stage two locks
loading we have to vent down the line so
you'll see another large white cloud
coming off of the strong rack that'll be
normal that'll happen transitioning to
one minute and 40 seconds we're going on
internal power now just a few seconds
away from the stage two locks load being
complete it's been almost nine years
since we've been in this position a lot
of work done by thousands of people to
get to this point all our eyes focus on
two now
Stage two lock FLOTUS closed out
propellant pills are complete dragon is
an auto Idol stage two locks
loadcomplete all fuel all oxidize are on
Falcon 9 one minute thirty four seconds
to go till launch brown gas close those
is starting
Falcon 9 is a start-up dragon is in
countdown FPS is armed for lunch under a
minute now the FTS the flight
termination system has been armed very
good spacex go for launch
spacex dragon
we're go for launch looks like this
handle t-minus 30 seconds
eight seven six five four three 20
seconds into flight stage one propulsion
is nominal flying crew and one deed
throttle down
we're throttling down to get ready for
the period of maximum dynamic pressure
we're in the bottle bucket
reports say all systems are go vehicle
is supersonic we've exceeded Mach 1 on
the Falcon 9 and what a throttle up
we're throttling back up the full powers
with roommates to copy one brother and
we heard that one Bravo call out that's
just the second aboard zone that they're
in they'll continue to be on this until
the first aid has done its job and they
switch over to the second at this point
Bob & Doug pulling about 2.3 G's 2.3
times the Earth's gravity already 1,500
miles per hour we've heard the call out
for EM back engine chill that's giving
the M back engine ready to light that
will come at about 244 in the flight
right now everything continuing to look
good next major event coming up is going
to be the triple we'll have main engine
cutoff of the nine first stage engines
stage separation and then ignition of
the second stage engine to continue to
carry astronauts into orbit coming up in
about 20 second m1d throttle down we
heard we're throttling down the merlin
engines on the first stage
and we have make out because Dawkins
their separation confirmed and
recognition all right we have stage
separation confirm the first age
beginning its flight back the second
stage being powered by that single
merlin 1d vacuum engine has ignited and
this battleship scary pop and dug into
orbit so they're gonna continue under
the power of this second stage is
propulsion is nominal which will cut off
at seco or second engine cut off at
about eight minutes and 44 seconds into
today's flight so a little over five
minutes to go still on this second stage
you're the call out to alpha so they're
now in the longest abort zone that
carries them all the way from about
North Carolina up the eastern seaboard
almost to Canada things looking good
though getting good call outs now for
propulsion on that second stage bobbing
up continuing to make their way into
orbit Dragon SpaceX nominal trajectory
that question of signaling Burton we go
thanks max dragon nominal trajectory all
right here in nominal trajectory the
dragon pointed in the right direction
continuing to make their flight uphill
hurt acquisition of signal Bermuda
that's one of the other ground stations
that they're using to get telemetry and
data back from this space they've to
propulsion is still nominal
a little over four minutes 40 seconds
into the flight Bob & Doug flying at
more than 5,600 miles already almost 200
miles downrange from the Kennedy Space
Center nominal trajectory continuing
and while they continue up it looks like
we are getting a view of the first stage
as well if on your right screen you can
see that first stage with the grid fins
deployed it's making its way back to
attempt to land on our drone ship of
course I still love you today we're just
about a minute a couple minutes away
from the entry burn and that's where
three of the nine Merlin engines do
ignite to help slow the vehicle down as
it re-enters back into the Earth's
atmosphere and then after the entry burn
will be the landing burn which is just a
single engine based on orbital
trajectory and you heard Naaman starting
to as I call out they are still on a
nominal trajectory on dragon still on
second stage and that's that em back
engine on second stage on your left
screen again on your right screen is
that first stage booster coming back
towards our drone ship of course I still
love you we're about a minute away from
entry burn while that second stage
continuing to power dragon into orbit
and if you're keeping an eye on that
timer that's gonna continue to burn
until 8 minutes and 44 seconds into
flight so a little over 2 minutes from
now we'll hear the call out Seco it will
then be a little baby purr for little in
orbit a little over three minutes until
dragon physically separates from the
second stage of the Falcon 9 after the
upper trajectory but I can copy down the
upper deck during continuing to check in
with Bob and Doug as they are on a
nominal trajectory just about 10 seconds
away from that first stage starting that
entry burn on your right screen we
should be able to see that view live
Stage one extra burn starter
and there is that entry bird sitting on
this burn lasts about 36 seconds long
stage 2 FPS is saved
all that entry burn continues for just
about a minute away from Seco we'll have
a number of events all happen in rapid
succession the second engine cutoff did
you want to be lunch before that stage
one landing burn shortly after actually
just within a few seconds of each other
it's such a cool view on your left
screen seeing Bob and Doug on dragon
right now you can see the displays that
they are seeing right now than central
guidance I'm back there although we are
coming up
25 seconds or so away from Seco or
second engine cutoff this is also the
point where Bob and Doug are
experiencing their highest g-force for
seeing the counter tick up to write
about your morning coffee Shannon you
heard Shannon so that just means they're
in their final abort zones if they were
to abort at this point but either be in
the board to orbit or to land off the
coast of Ireland sandy by 4 seconds one
line of confirmation and back Darla step
and bear cut down they do in London
where affirmation of Seco second engine
cutoff now we are waiting for our first
stage to make its way to our drone ship
of course I still love you I can stay
sex on a little insertion justice what
you're seeing on your screen is a live
view of our drone ship where our first
stage will be coming down looks like we
lost that live view but wait for
confirmation of that landing shortly
here doc another station successful life
and there you can see on your screen
Falcon 9 has landed this was the first
Falcon 9 to carry to orbit so very
exciting for us
and as you can see on your right screen
Bob and Doug are still making their way
to their targeted orbits I want you to
recovery one so exciting today it
doesn't stop it does not stop all right
we did we did here again that call-out
good orbital insertion so that means
Falcon 9 and dragon right now exactly
where they're supposed to be can we need
a FRC on arc everyone and it's right in
about 12 minutes when dragon will
separate looks like we saw a zero-g
indicator floating around there I know
Bob and Doug oh us a little bit about
what exactly that is that they brought
up with them and before separation
before dragon initiate separation from
the second stage they do make sure to
make they they do ensure that the
vehicle is not spinning and it is in
good condition before we separate that's
right the upper stage does small
attitude maneuver using cold gas
thrusters built into the rocket body
itself exactly so we do expect that
separation to occur in about a minute
from now but they do wait until they
have full confirmation that it is ready
to separate such cool views I cannot get
over this view that we are seeing right
now Bob and Doug on the right screen
inside of crew dragon out in space yeah
already 200 kilometers over planet earth
or a little over 124 miles
traveling in excess of 2700 meters
27,000 meters per second or about 16,000
miles per hour
again we're just standing by that
separation event should be coming up
shortly and they'll begin a series of
checks on the Draco thrusters that are
going to be used to maneuver and then
power dragon on its flight to the
International Space Station standing by
for separation expected losses signal
walls it sounds like we hadn't expected
l OS lost a signal with one of the
ground stations waiting for confirmation
out of that struggling separation
confirmed dragon separation confirmed
there is a great view right in front of
you and there's that call out dragon is
now officially making its way to the
International Space Station today dragon
SpaceX with that separation call we have
a few words for you from our falcon 1995
dragon chief engineer on dragon the
ground
Bob Doug on behalf of the entire launch
team thanks for flying with Falcon 9
today we hope you enjoyed the ride and
wish you a great mission thanks Paula
congratulations to you and the f9 team
for the first human ride for Falcon 9
and it was incredible appreciate all the
hard work and thanks for the great rides
of space Bobby oh wow I like it
proud of you guys and the rest of the
team thank you so much for what she had
done for us today putting America back
into low Earth orbit uh perform the
Florida coast
all right so Bob and Doug are in firm
nominal eCos activation and serious
section Draco checkouts nosecone deploys
in progress gap y'all we're monitoring
the core here in Hawthorne giving the
crew a heads up that we have
confirmation the nose cone is deploying
so again that nose cone is going to open
up a little bit more than 90 degrees
goes up to about I think 105 degrees and
that's gonna expose the actual docking
ring and the hatch that they're gonna be
going through once they attach to the
International Space Station and also
four of those Draco thrusters we call
them the forward bulkhead thrusters
they're gonna be used for these major
phase burns or firings of those
thrusters to actually raise their orbit
gradually over the coming hours also
heard good activation of the Eclipse
that's the environmental control and
life support system that's everything
controlling their atmosphere just
keeping drag in a nice safe habitable
environment where they're gonna be
living for the next 19 hours until they
arrive at the space station right
exactly and Falcon nines job may be done
for today but the mission is not over
crew dragons job is not done
as you can see Bob and Doug are still
inside crew dragon making their way it
will be a 19-hour trip to the
International Space Station before they
dock tomorrow morning in such cool views
I love that we can get these live views
here and see and watch what they're
doing now that they are in orbit
it's it's incredible just be looking
over their shoulder to be along for the
ride
and we're gonna be with them and we're
gonna be with all of you the entire way
for their journey to the space station
we're gonna be covering live throughout
Bob and Doug will obviously have a sleep
period where they'll get about eight
hours of sleep a little bit later today
before they wake up for all their final
approach one of the major things we are
looking forward to in the next couple of
hours is going to be their first turn at
the controls so they're actually going
to be
using those touchscreen displays to take
control and manually pilot dragon will
walk you through what that's going to
look like and assuming we have some good
ground station coverage we'll be able to
get views from right inside dragon
looking over their shoulder as they
manipulate the controls at the display
but I mean if we had a smooth ride
uphill both stages at the Falcon 9 doing
their job
placing Bob and Doug in orbit I mean
this is this is a day this is a
historical day this is us kicking off
that new era of spaceflight that we've
all been talking about and longing for
since the space shuttle program came to
an end in 2011 yeah the weather the
weather cooperated yes second time's a
charm right all right so Dave for the
history book books as you can see we
have lost some live signal there but the
mission still continues and we're going
to send it over to KSC to continue
broadcasting live with them also you
know the excellent yeah Jesse and Dan we
are just in awe over here and I woke up
this morning and looked at the weather
forecast I was like man we're gonna be
back here on Sunday but we we did it and
the room cleared out everybody was
outside watching and then and inside the
lights were shaking the cameras were
shaking Lauren came back in with tears
in her eyes this is really amazing I I
can't believe it I thought with my own
eyes this is I'm a little bit speechless
um just so grateful that we got them up
there and there's a lot more to go a lot
more to go but I'm so happy they're safe
right now I'm just so happy yeah Leland
you were talking about it it's amazing
what we can do when we work together yes
American astronauts on an American
rocket from American soil showing you
what Americans can do when we come
together as a team and blast
Doug and Bob off to the cosmos this is
this is what it's all about and their
families and everyone is working
together to to take them up to space
safely so I'm I don't know what to say
we want to go over to Darrell at OSP -
he's there with the administrator who
hopefully has more words than we do
because we're still kind of speechless
Darrell incredible here Murray at the
Operations Support Building where a
chorus of applause has been happening
from the beginning of launch and
throughout the various stages some very
special guests were here to watch it
that includes President Donald Trump
vice president Mike Pence and NASA
Administrator Jim Brian Stein who joins
me now and you were with the president
and the vice president America's back
launching human astronauts again tell me
how you feel about that and tell me
about the president watching launch and
what happened then so this has been a
long time coming it's been nine years
since we've launched American astronauts
on American Rockets from American soil
and now it's done
we have done it it's been way too long I
want to give a lot of credit to Charlie
Bolden he was my predecessor as the NASA
Administrator he fought hard for this
program at a time when it didn't get any
any support in Congress we now have an
administration that is fully supportive
of our spaceflight initiatives not just
on the exploration discovery going to
the moon onto Mars but also from a space
force perspective our budgets are going
up things were strong and today was just
it was a just an amazing day you know
one of the things the president did
right out of the gate when he became
president is he created what's called
the national space Council and he put
the vice president as chairman of the
National Space Council and on that
national space Council you've got the
Secretary of Defense and the Secretary
of State and the Secretary of Commerce
the Secretary of Transportation the
Secretary of Education the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs all of these different
amazing individuals that deal with space
day in and day out a lot of people don't
realize how many parts of the federal
government deal with space and the vice
president invited those members of the
national space council here as well so
we we just had and then we had members
of Congress bipartisan members of
Congress Republicans and Democrats who
have been involved in supporting this
program you know for for a long time now
so I'll just tell you I
I'm breathing a sigh of relief but I
will also tell you I am NOT going to
celebrate until Bob and Doug are home
safely tomorrow they're going to dock to
the International Space Station tonight
I'm heading to Houston to be at the the
Johnson Space Center when that happens
so it is it is a bit it's a bit of a
relief that the nosecone is now open
it's now deployed which means that you
know now we're going to go into some
some burns we're going to have some
phasing burns we're going to have some
some you know boosting burns and we're
gonna get as much as we can in alignment
with the International Space Station as
early as possible here but also I know
it's hard but you know the big thing
that we need to do now is we've got to
get Bob and Doug who have now gone
through this exercise twice they need to
get some rest but I can guarantee you
there will be no rest for a good good
amount of time while they're up there in
orbit and they are certainly on their
way and a lot of people joining us for